all right
yeah
so we're in the airport
I love it
are we on live stream
okay
we might get started team
Mia Clarke are you ready to roll
you ready
we might get going okay
no do you want to start
are you ready you're gonna start from
there
okay
um well look welcome to this
um
Workshop around assets and activity
plans welcome to those that are joining
us on live stream we have
some apology so Tom uh councilor
Campbell councilor Soper and pania the
apology is there any other apologies
rare I had also registered with everyone
because she's in offshore as well who's
that she's offshore too
yeah
right so
um
Brian and all sort of outline the
purpose of this Workshop in a minute but
it's important to remember
that we are live streaming this in the
purpose of the workshop is to
not make decisions but to explore
um this the situation what the actual
position is and then understand
the possible potential outcomes which
will then informed decision when we get
into more formal decision making
um through committees and then Council
so it is important to remember that it's
important that also we make sure we
protect their right to be able to stay
in the debate by keeping an open mind
about what the options might be so if we
can just remember that there isn't any
public involvement in these workshops
it's a chance for councilors in
manafinoa to discuss matters
um
sit up you know through a form of live
stream public consultation will follow
um
and always be open around the
discussions so
keep on clear on that
radio Rihanna
counselors so just very brief
introduction to the workshop this is the
final
um activity Workshop so following this
Workshop all of your initial questions
and feedback will be considered by the
asset and activity managers as they put
together their asset plans for you to
consider and
um
as the budgets are put together so
you've got in front of you the options
that will be discussed today as well as
for anyone who hasn't yet finalized
their thoughts about other options for
consideration the managers all use these
as they put to pull together their
reports for your discussion and
deliberation
um so I think without further Ado we can
move into the first
topic yeah Rodeo so it's three Waters so
welcome Russell and Aaron
good morning councilors I've got the uh
guess the great job of uh running
through that today but I thought before
we actually started I would actually uh
recognize some of my colleagues
um on our table over here who have
actually who are pro who are the
technical brains of our of our business
so if you add up their actual I guess
their practical experience and their
actual input into our infrastructural
networks
um
together you start with nine
between them
so I guess really what I'm saying is
when it comes to some hard questions
they'll be the uh the brains of the
organizations
um they're the they're the engine room
and have been for a very very long time
in their business so
um lots of the well most of the
information that's here today is really
um because of lots of what they've done
through over a long time but I think
that's actually one of the strengths
that we actually see
from our organization is that we
actually do have that deep knowledge
about what's going on so
um when it comes to question times we'll
need to I guess have a little bit of a
team
effect on some of those but I'm happy to
take some questions I'd started with a
few slides but ended up with about 30 so
it will be a little bit of a whirlwind
on the way past here but if there's
something you wish to ask just go ahead
so today you really just want to run
through those topics and really I've
tried to keep it at a reasonably
strategic level rather than necessarily
get down to the nuts and bolts so it's
it's going to be reasonably high level
I'm going to just run through what sort
of stuff that we do which hopefully is a
refresher for most and talk about some
of those key issues some budgets what's
driving what what the sort of things
that we think will be useful for you to
as decision making time comes along
um also recognizing that there is quite
a bit of change in that sector and our
staff as one of our greatest assets um
both within this building and also in
our operations team that we run so
making sure that we understand how we'll
deal with that having a plan a little
bit about what happens if um an October
with the elections and bits and pieces
but also recognizing at the end of the
day the numbers that we're going to
flash past you here
um about the resourcing of the sector
about how do you actually do some of the
stuff because some of the numbers are
reasonably
significant and
will need a lot of extra resource and
thinking about how we along with all of
our other colleagues up and down the
country will be doing some other things
on the way past
it's a very brief um I guess hopefully
overview of the uh affordable water
reform which
I understand you've had several
briefings on but what we do know is that
the entities have indicated that the
first two years of the of our ltp are
what they're going to take and deliver
so from a strategic perspective you have
a bit of control to make sure that in
years one and two of our long-term plan
other things that are going to be
started or done
for the if the new entity is formed and
I think that's a really key point so if
your priority
is potentially different from what you
think the entity's priority might be
going forward you need to strategize
about whether you do it now whether you
don't whether you leave it in whether
you leave it out because
um on year three four and five they may
choose something different from what you
would otherwise have chosen
just a question your questions as you go
along or right at the internet
um
might just do a few of them but happy to
take them on the way fast
no just just starting off with
affordable water reform now
um I'm not I'm not trying to be
hilarious here but obviously if the
government signaled
um multiple times that they're going to
be
potentially borrowing 180 billion
dollars for the three Waters reform and
and this is they've stated that over and
over again now how does the word
affordable fit in with us being a part
owner of that 180 billion dollar debt
other stuff's supposed to answer that
yeah I'll take that one over someone's
written affordable up there yeah yeah
I'll take that one so it's it was
changed by the government yeah and it
was a political sort of oh so that's a
political name sidestep
in my view potentially but anyway yeah
but but equally the thing and it's good
you've raised us because you know we're
here to determine what we should do with
our infrastructure yeah yeah I know so
you know let's just continue on and um
determine you know where we go to with
it if it if it changes in the reality is
it is going to change in some way shape
or form a respect of what happens in
October
I mean that's a reality it may not be in
the structure in terms of the governance
model if it goes a certain way but it is
going to change because three would have
started under the national
and that is I guess one of the points
that I made earlier was that we actually
need to be able to be agile enough to
understand what we we're going to do
next if something does change rather
than go oh gosh what are we gonna do and
start again yeah we need to have a plan
and then actually Focus about how we
leverage off either A or B yeah and then
revisit that once October's come and
gone so
wahoo uh you throw yourself to you just
just to close the previous discussion
out into trying us back
um look we've made our position very
clear from a organization point of view
in relation to the affordability and
what it means from our community I think
that is it's on that political lens that
you just previously talked about
um today I think you need to stay
focused on what we need to do should
um from a three Waters perspective
regardless and that's what I think Russ
was going to be focusing on what you
need to do in your own asset side of it
as as it is current asset owners to make
sure that we're doing the best for our
community going forward so
um just want to highlight that and say
we'll we'll battle the affordable side
on a separate manner
foreign
just a quick reflection on what Michael
just said um entity J which is a Target
South and I was very keen to uh go early
so the deer line the government said is
2026 so we're a little ways off that
obviously
um and uh after some discussions with
Michael
um I've gone back to
um the interview which is the national
transition unit and said we're not
prepared to go early we want to one see
what the government the new government
dishes it up and what position they will
have
um and the
earliest we want to go is March 2025 so
that doesn't sit well with some of my
colleagues
um but the way I'll read the tea leaves
at the moment is that everybody's got to
agree to go you can't have a majority
vote so we've got I think seven councils
and a tiger thousand six car degree to
go early and the seventh one be
compelled to go that's my understanding
but that's still not clear yet so we'll
need some we will need to know that yeah
because if we're deciding what we do in
the next year or two or three
um we'll need to know whether that's
hours to control or whether we're
determined by the majority that sits in
the entity of the entity J at the moment
yeah yeah yeah but irrespective we step
back and we just look at the sort of
what what's the best thing for us to do
a city wherever it sits and whenever it
sits there okay and I think that sorry
the final key part of that from our
perspective is that we've seen a number
of uh guests plans from the interview
about fearing dates where people could
be asked to join but our understanding
is the minister is actually holds the
final decision on that and the minister
will actually see will sit when an
entity will actually go be joined so
um because that's how how we position
ourselves and how we continue to be
ready as ready as we can for all of the
available options but I guess what I'm
signaling is that while the minister
will probably put the final stamp on it
I suspect that if there's opposition and
one particular entity as opposed to
another he'll go with the easy options
first so we're all click we're wanting
to go into the J will be right at the
very front end
and it's being talk about money
available as well so yeah but I guess
we've got to do what's right for us just
just a quick question did we assume a
council position on that I'm we may have
done I just I don't recall
I'm looking across the table now
um when we're going
uh about our lack of willingness to join
until March 25th well they they just it
didn't come from the other councils it
came no no but did Council form that
opinion
yes yes
okay sorry no I just couldn't recall
just didn't want to get hooked up into
the transfer of debt to it I understand
the rationale why yeah so let's let's
get back on track thank you
things are probably much more
comfortable
we'll talk about some of some of our
assets
um and really
the slide this first slide has really
just tries to point out the scope and
depth of our
yes our asset base across
um a district which includes treatment
plants um reservoirs pump stations and
we are dealing with the three Waters so
we are dealing with water storm water in
our search so
um that also includes we we also have
the operations facilities and we have
about I think we've looked at 35 direct
staff
operating those plus air Contracting a
wider Contracting team
we've made a reasonably broad statement
that we think our assets are in pretty
good health and I guess that's the
challenge that we will see over time
about what that actually means and how
do you demonstrate that but I guess part
of the the kpis and those sorts of
things that you see in any reporting are
part of what you do
um and we also suggest that there has
been a good history of investment and
that's really why we've got uh some of
the lower capacity lower um I guess
faults in some of our networks than you
see obviously Wellington's an area that
comes to mind where they seem to
regularly featuring the media if their
water mains bursting and those sorts of
things whereas you don't necessarily see
the same
so I thought I'd bring some pictures to
the to the story today
um so this is about the foul surge
Network and really on the left it's
really just the areas where
um reticulated surge
or disposal is actually available to
Residents and we also use those
boundaries at the moment to actually say
if you're inside the lines you can do it
if you're not you can't
and I guess that's part of the future
challenge about where spatial planning
will go for the city and what the city
looks like going forward and being ready
um once again you put your two two to
three year window on it what what do you
want to compare to 10 years we have less
potential direct input so we're those
areas are obviously Bluff Maui
otatara invercargill and Kennington
so that's so there's reasonable big
chunks of air will that don't
necessarily have reticulated sewage on
it Russ just on there are the areas
within that that are easy to easier to
expand because of
the way the infrastructure is
constructed or is it pretty much it's
the same problem whichever way you
expand can we come back to that when we
actually we have some budgets that
actually suggest some of those things
are considerations and options for you
to think about where you might invest
and in the middle slide is really just
sort of shows at uh where some of the
bigger pipes and some of the important
things are some of those big those red
lines are actually
um Air important in our critical Mains
which pick up
the disposal from the individual
properties transmit it through smaller
pipes to a bigger pipe and then
generally are pumped down to Clifton so
there are some of those pipes that are
really quite critical and quite key to
us concerning to be able to deliver a
network service across the whole of the
district
and on the right hand side I grabbed for
one of the early asset plans is about
the infiltration so infiltration is when
you get rainfall typically rainfall
and how does that storm water get into
our sewer Network which puts pressure on
it so the blue is good and Red's bad so
that that probably is a reflection on
the age of the network in those areas
and if you think about the red area
that's really the historical the old old
historical invercargill from the 1900s
onwards and like that's where the effort
has to go on because the more you put in
the pipes the bigger the pipes have to
be the more you have to treat so going
forward how you manage that is really
part of the a key consideration so you
know Green sort of probably the newer
area so you'd expect it to be better so
that's just really
helps us a little bit to understand how
our networks operate so sorry let Russ
that one on the right or my right yeah
it is
um
that that's the coloring's specifically
related to stormwater or to storm answer
no it is so it's a sewer networks yes
but it talks about
um infiltration infiltration is really
when something gets into the pipes that
you would and Russell Keynes the expert
in this world but it's about
um you know dry weather flow and wet
with a flow so suddenly when it rains we
get more more stuff in the pipes and
that's coming from the ground or from
cross connections and those sorts of
things and that's what we have to
continue to manage and it is a
reflection of the age of network it was
one of us one of those things okay
moving on to the stormwater
Network
um it's on the right hand side we'll
start so most the red lines
predominantly all the red lines there
are stock Banks or systems where
environment Southland manage those
catchments and that's
the flood protection schemes that were
developed from the 1980s when we had the
84 flood and I'm sure councilors are
aware that recently that Council has
work been working on the stead Street
Stock bank and the Cobb Road stop range
so they are the two stop banks that
Council currently looks after in the
stormwater and so I guess the urban
areas the once again the red lines are
the more important pipes and the green
lines are the are the bigger pipes so
we've tried to show you where the big
Network and it's reasonably well
distributed across the city and um
it has been I guess we just need to
continue to watch how um the resilience
and sea level rise affects the design
how you go forward because their sea
level rises so our capacity to get rid
of stormwater decreases a little bit so
it's just a reflection on the network
oh sorry I don't want to miss alistair's
piece so
this is the water reticulation Network
and really we've just picked the big
pipes anything a bigger than 200
diameter
so so on the left hand side is really
the supply network and it's really shows
what is currently taken from ranks home
and and then move through the city
through a whole range of those bigger
pipes and then distributed across the
city and through into Bluff and the red
dots are where our reservoirs in storage
or major event like macaroon has a
standpipe for the network but everywhere
else the red dots are a reservoir for
storing water so that's the The Wider
picture
and on the right hand side is the is the
area where we currently Supply water to
the urban areas so we Supply water and
Bluff and we Supply water and then the
avocado urban area so
and those plans the right hand plan has
been extracted from the district plan
because
that's what we're indicating from a
spatial perspective of if you live
inside the Blue Line you can get water
if you live outside the blue light at
the moment you can't
and Broad terms sorry
just a little bit of a an overview
diagram of how it all happens and
which is what is taken from the Reedy
River it's pumped and treated at Brinks
home
brought through by some big pipes and
it's stored at our reservoirs and you'll
all have seen places like hopefully
waikiwis and ones at gala Street and
then it's distributed to The Wider
Network into people's houses through
much smaller pipes so there is quite an
extent of pipe work across all of our
city
and sorry the bottom diagram is a very
similar process diagram but it's just a
little bit little little sorry it didn't
come up too good
just sort of show a little bit about
um
stepping back to the first sewer pipes
on the top left hand corner the big blue
lines really is trying to show how much
was put in those decades and what it
really shows is that we've got some
really big big lines so during those
decades there were lots of pipes
installed in the city so that's when the
growth spurges in the city occurred
um which are great the problem being is
when they all reach the end of life so
you've actually got to go back and fix
them all at the same time so we are a
little bit blocky and you can see that
there's sort of been a big burst in the
um
1960s to the 60s to 70s and then it sort
of been reasonably
low so as those pipes from the left hand
side of those graphs become aged so our
Demand on our Network
becomes greater as well so
and if you notice the reflection on the
stormwater
is similar but not the same it's we've
done more since the um since the 80s so
that's what this I guess
we'll read lines on the bottom so
let's just sort of get a feel of the the
network as a whole
on the right hand side is really just
um a condition rating of the pipe so
to me you really wanted to look for
where the um the very poor and the and
the poor areas are I know that the um
the purple and the blue so and our pot
networks and reasonable condition but by
age It is Well consumed so we shouldn't
rest on our Laurels and say that we've
got a really great pipeline we knew we
need to continue our renewal program
because as pipes get to the end of their
lives they do need to be replaced
similar
age profile for the water but in this
case this is just really showing a
little bit about
um
the distribution of the size of pipes
across anywhere so what it really shows
is that we've got a whole lot of water
mains that are 100 millimeters and we've
got a very few on the right hand side at
600 which are Air Supply means
but within that we have quite a
different material type
and there are sections of that profile
with the asbestos cement being the the
big right hand Chunk on that pie diagram
and and that's a I guess a series of um
a type of pipe that
um was installed reasonably frequently
during the 60s and 70s it has it is
proving to have a uh A Life That's
relatively shortened than other some
other materials and it's the area where
we continue to focus on on our renewal
so we don't necessarily want them to to
fail obviously a failed water main can
cause quite a lot of damage so yes
that's where the efforts continues to
need to go into and when you see the
performed programs that this is what biu
looks like for the renewals team they're
addressing the asbestos cement pipes
because they're reaching towards the end
of the life and that's something that
over a long period Alistair and The
Wider team have been sampling those
pipes continuing to estimate their lives
to lock for what the future
life of those pipes will be
just to finish the asset overview
I've included
the asset evaluation and I believe I've
got it right pulled it together so what
it says is that we've got a replacement
cost of air three Waters of acid of
about 1.2 billion dollars now Michael
might hopefully tell me I've got it
right
um but it so what it's broken down is
about 400 million dollars of um so uh
before and that sort of split brings me
equally across the three assets but
inside what I pulled together was the
sum of the depreciation the depreciation
is is as we would see it is how much are
you consuming each year of your network
and how much should you be investing
somewhere in your network to actually
keep it renewed over its lifetime
so in instance
the number I'm trying to encourage you
to remember is around the 18 million
dollars is the target number
hopefully Patricia's not throwing too
many things at me with that number but
that's the number we should be investing
in the three Waters networks that's
every year for the life of the asset so
we've got a hundred year life so that's
that's what you convert into
what's the middle number middle call
um that's the optimized appreciation
sets its current Book value that's how
much it's consumed so it would cost us
1.2 billion to replace it so its current
value is 543 million so by that you can
see you're about
consume seven twelfths of its life so
you've got 5 12 of them of its life left
so you're about halfway which is about
where you probably want to be in terms
of your network and I think that's that
to me is one of the numbers that said
we've been continuing to invest in there
but I would suspect lots of councils
their current value is much lower as a
percentage so and that numbers derived
purely from an accounting standard
it's based around an accounting standard
but it has quite a bit of engineering
input but
yeah
uh three yourself chair
um just Russell highlighted that's the
number you should be spending on your
network I just want to um say Russell um
that's a bit low
um and the reason I say that is because
that's what you should be spending to
maintain your existing network with the
existing services with no growth
um so just want to highlight that's the
minimum minimum yeah
right
um that appreciation number is that base
now obviously it's if we did this two
years ago
with the cost of doing business is that
significantly more the number the number
is based on June 22 which is the last
revaluation period okay and the cost of
of building and has increased I mean
Patricia and I continue to wrestle with
that one
yes so
um through your chair the um that figure
went up across all Council assets by
over 10 million
when we did that revaluation so the
depreciation charge went up over 10
million more than what we had budgeted
and we had already
had to go it look indicating what we
thought the increase would be so it's
going exponentially that's the asset
very well but the asset value determines
yeah it determines the depreciation but
the that is because of the cost of doing
business it's now much more expensive to
replace these assets yeah
the
yeah I'm just a couple of issues about
the alternative water supply that we're
drilling for at the moment
given that we've got um potentially two
years before the entity gets up and runs
I guess strategically which is what
we're looking at today
um it's important I think that we've
either got that sorted the water
alternative water supply or we don't
have it sorted anything in between I
think leaves us in no man's land
so if we have it sorted then the entity
takes it over and it will manage it with
the cost that goes with it if we don't
then it will get into a long line of
um I guess
um
priorities for entity J which means we
might sit behind from say Queenstown
Lakes districts are growth so a couple
of questions around around that I think
we're covering that later we will get to
that yeah okay and that's that's
certainly a nice segue into the next
slide which really starts to sort of set
that um
strategic level and
at a high level
these are the core assets to to your
community you know
he will struggle without those three
assets being delivered so
what we do also recognize is that the
kpis that have been set
will continue for the next two years at
a similar similar of what they are we
know that the The Entity is also working
on a range of those and my understanding
is that we don't necessarily need to
consult on those kpis but they still
continue to be a good reflection
this is probably one of our big game
changes I think for our Council about
what do you do and be being ready
do recognize that going forward that
there is the potential that there is
diminished um Community Connection so
how you see the priority for an entity
where you only have one have have a a
different number of seats at their table
has to be something you need to think
about and I guess one of the
consequential issues that we see from
that is that more often than not when
we're doing
um
renewal work there's a lot of
integration across our business between
roading and the other places where we
try to
and hopefully successfully make sure we
put pipes in before we seal roads and
those sorts of things we're now going to
have another layer of that sort of don't
remove from us and we'll have to work
harder in those places so for instance
as we do things like
refurbishment areas or those things
where we look at the age and we can
internally negotiate with ourselves to
make sure that the pipes are up perhaps
replaced slightly earlier so we don't
have to come back that's the piece that
we won't necessarily have that direct
in-house control over and I guess that's
the next layer of that lack of direct
connection we have success with power
industry but it's um thing that still at
Arms Reach so yeah couple of questions
ringing then yeah I think a guideline
perhaps successful it will be is is how
well the Polytech reform has gone so I
think that's your key indicator
um through each year so
are you inferring that there are some
aspects of infrastructure we might bring
forward earlier so that we can have
responsibilities
in the next two years and so what you're
talking about
I'm going to ask that one very carefully
as you go through and look at the
budgets that will signal today as well
as the rest of your budgets you'll need
to think carefully about what is the
priority and which which things that you
think will actually still have higher
priority so you might time them at a
different time I know that the entity
has used words like there's not to be
any gaming going on but I'm not sure
what that actually means but as a
council you have the opportunity to set
your priorities for the next
two years yeah could and you need to
have a plan B that actually says if if
there's a change somewhere in this
storyline what is two to five years look
like so and so I think also Trish what
what probably your question related to
in terms of what Russell was talking
about is whilst we've had control of
both our roading assets and our three
Waters assets that enabled us like with
City Center and streets to actually go
we're going to actually go through and
replace all the three Waters
infrastructure a few years early so that
we don't have to come back and tear the
street up after we've just invested a
whole lot of money in it we'll that'll
become a much more complex negotiation
when it's with an outside entity
right
um just a bit of guidance on that um
Nobby and I went to Dunedin uh must be a
year and a half ago met with the
uh was a Dia in the in the previous
Minister was there
um and I asked the question of the DIA
about our 10-year plans and our third
year of structure plans and they told us
quite clearly that they are thrown out
the door
they they are gone whatever we have
strategically planned
in
what I what I can help with that is that
um alistair's been working closely
providing information on our planning
for the three Waters to the NTU unit so
they can actually effectively start to
build their own prioritization plan and
I guess all the councils are looking to
have them to provide that information so
they are drawing information from from
the councils because that's where the
best information is about what's your
asset condition what are you propose I
mean that's that's true but that's
that's and that's what I expected but I
mean you know no better brains than the
ones we have here yet they they told us
directly
yeah like but what I can tell you is
that they have directly said the first
two years you control yeah and just the
sort of Trish's question
um I think you know what we have to
determine and talking to some other
councils at the LG conference they've
one in particular decided what we are
going to take the position that we will
make sure we hand it over in the best
possible quality yeah and partly that
was sort of they can't come back and say
well it was you hand it to us in a below
average position so you have to live
with that but equally I think for us
it's you know is there anything critical
within air infrastructure that you know
just says look
if if there is a bit of sort of inertia
around investment for a period of time
we probably should be really addressing
that now yes we probably incur some more
debt
um or ratepayers paid but if you step
back from there it's it's the best thing
to do because the consequences of not
doing that yeah
attire if that makes sense so I think
it's just trying to understand that sort
of piece so suppress if I run through
these next couple of slides because it's
actually a really good segue into
um some of those really key issues and
next couple slides to talk about the
issues and then it goes down into what
those projects are
and the first one really says as we've
been talking about
how do you make sure that the key
projects actually do happen
what we also need to be thinking at one
of going forward is how do we actually
make sure we don't have risks and
failure of critical assets so some of
those pipes that I showed you that were
the red pipes are really really key to
make sure that the city continues to to
operate and function well and
council's invested strongly in
um strengthening their water supply
lines in the last few years and I think
that's reaped lots of benefits but we've
got some of the projects going and the
next slide which actually say some
things there's some other areas where we
probably want to pull some of those
things forward
we do need to make sure that we actually
still have a healthy and safe
work environment because we do have a
wide team so that's not it's it's there
because it's actually really important
maintaining our skill level is really
really difficult in today's market both
for
us as a council
um
and also our contractors
we've been fortunate for as I've started
with that we have some of the most
knowledgeable people in in the industry
and certainly
within our assets here
but we're not going to be here forever
and from a city perspective how do you
make sure you keep that that knowledge
base
even to the point for the next two years
how do you make sure you do some of
these big things because we don't have
lots of that resource spear resource
sitting around when you see the numbers
you'll understand what we're talking
about
it's essential that we actually continue
to develop relationships with ewe some
of the consenting issues that we have
are absolutely vital that we have a
strong working relationship and it's
strengthened
and that partnership is actually
key to that decision making certainly
around some of the storm so the first
sewer discharges from Clifton and Bluff
about what those uh have huge impacts
upon decision making and
the real key to that is having a strong
relationship
we also have seen and Heard lots about
the environmental performance so how we
discharge stormwater and what sort of
quality improvements that'll be
something that we'll need to work
closely with es on going forward but
there's
certainly every signal that you see
everywhere says that we're going to have
to start to do better with their
stormwater discharges you know hence
we've got
some rain Gardens and some other tree
water treatment facilities but most of
our Stillwater at the moment discharges
straight to stream or straight to Sea so
how we actually put some of those
treatment for issues or treatment
opportunities before they discharge is
their responsibility will be part of the
ongoing challenge
we have a number of consents that are
getting towards the completion and there
is some real pressure to push ahead on
some of those so there is some
lots of urgency to actually start those
conversations to understand what we're
doing in some of our forward budgets
recognize that we need those consents
but until you understand what the
conditions are you can't necessarily
always predict what you have to do to it
and I guess if you're not allowed if the
decision isn't to discharge to to water
then you have to discharge to land so
each of those have completely different
treatment options have completely
different cost options when you actually
go through it so we've tried to
see some of those and put some numbers
around that
we're also signaling that there is
actually a need for us to
increase our Network knowledge so we
want to think a bit more about how we
can understand how the network will
perform so that when you come and say
can we as a spatial planning for the
wider City develop in a certain area we
can actually have with a higher degree
of certainty some of those models that
need to be
um out there so that's something that
we've got models but they need to be
refreshed and increased in capacity and
that's
but I guess part of that planning
we also need to recognize that there's
been lots of storm events you know
auckland's the prime case and I think
the expectation of The Wider
um
public and whole of new zealanders that
we are going to see more storm events
and are we ready and what does it mean
for us and there is a whole bunch of
work that we need to be thinking about
where our Overland flow pass when you
saw the storm event in Auckland I would
doubt any Council would be able to
handle that much rain over that
intensity in that location so what does
it mean to us and what happens next and
are we ready to be ready for the that
big event because we will we should be
and we need to be
and as an issue there is obviously the
ongoing conversation with environment
South and about who owns to stop Bank on
stead Street and they own all the other
stop Banks why do we have one or why do
we have two
just need to work through that over time
and once again it's recognizing one of
our key strategic issues uh we don't
actually have that greatest strength in
either contractors and or the design
capabilities locally to actually do all
the works we need so where does where do
those people come from and how do we
manage them
that's sort of the high level and if I
just go through the projects and then we
can
get on amongst this
um so I've tried to break to the
projects that we we think are really the
high level ones where you need to start
thinking about your options around and
two things is the delivery piece that
are the sort of building pieces and then
there's some planning pieces on the next
slide so the big things that we've we're
highlighting to you as uh key issues in
our big numbers
uh the brakes home supply lines and you
have committed to that so that's
actually you're well Advanced and when
you saw the network it's it's really
good
um we're highlighting that the mersey
street
um
pumped main is a critical asset that we
think we need to have a better plan how
we will
renew its capacity whether it's a new
main or it's a a reline of the existing
pipe or both and that's something that
we shouldn't be waiting too long to do
because it's a pipe that's really
important to us and it's not
um
performing that well when it's at the
end of its age so it's a big pipe
it takes a lot of the city sewage pump
from mersey Street towards Clifton
for it to run to the end of its life and
not be replaced before then we would
have significant operational issues for
the city
the alternative water supply there's
been lots of conversations about how
that will be and I think some of the
guests the consequential
um issues from that
is the capacity the extra capacity we're
able to supply to Bluff our obviously
has a whole lot of
um
alternative slash emergency water
supplies and what is that what
opportunity does that does that bring to
invercargill
at the moment
we are able to supply Bluff
we've got a commitment to supply some
water to the development Ocean Beach
but in reality additional supply for
Bluff for any big water industry would
require investment Across The Wider
Network to make it happen so for
instance if any big development
and that area or our Aurora needs lots
of water then we need to find a way to
supply lots of water to that place so
Bluff operates
that's normal BAU capacity but if
there's lots of development so
with the rural development you have the
opportunity to supplement the network in
both in both ways but there is some big
dollars
we've got some projects on the options
list that talk about uh odatara and the
phototara is an area where the spatial
desire for the city is to grow and fill
in some of the areas we have
parts of the parts of that Network that
are operating if everybody was to join
who could join will operate but there's
not a lot of extra capacity we need to
strengthen and replace some of those
pipes and pump stations out there
the understanding for that is
well we've done some modeling but we
need to do some more but that tells us
that we need to replace a number of
pipes
if we want to I guess fill in some of
the areas there's big areas that are
chopped out of the Red Square out of
outatara if you want to fill them all in
and let people build in other areas
we're going to need to invest in the
network or someone will have to
someone's a big delivery projects um
concerning for Bluff is probably one is
one of the ones that Russell Keane and a
wider team are working on was that
consent is up for completion and
2020 end of 25 so by then we have to
have a resource consent or an
application in place so there's lots of
work and lots of efforts going into that
and then Clifton comes along and 24-9
um and that is a baker Beast and the um
you know the understanding of how you
might
deliver that whether it's discharged to
land or water is actually part of that
relationship that we need to continue to
work with Ewing I think I just want to
draw some attention to those ones in
particular Clifton because 2029 feels
like it's a really long way away
um I know that there's councils that
have been trying to negotiate their
Wastewater consents for close to 10
years
um whatever we do in this space we're
expecting it to require either a a
significant upgrade to the treatment
plant or to pipette to a land discharge
area that will be significant as well
which means we're talking if at least
probably two to three years in
construction of whatever that solution
looks like which when you then start
getting to being into Construction in
2026 that doesn't leave us a lot of time
to figure out all of our different
options and come up with what we're
going to start start building so as much
as it feels like it's a long way away we
really need to move
I think it's a couple of questions so
yeah like just just really for what
Aaron said now I was going to talk to
her later I've got other stuff to bring
in later about that but about the
consent and the thinking about the
consent now this is a key thing 2029
that even though you see that it seems
like a long way away it's not but this
is one of those crossover things is it
our problem or is it entities J J's
problem because I mean if we start doing
planning and stuff now in our two-year
window that we have I mean
look I've just looked at New Plymouth
what they did they bought 41 hectares
100 acres of land specifically for
discharge we we I don't know where we'd
find that amount of land
um to pipe it to for Plan B if we can't
put it out to sea so is that something I
mean
are we are we worried about it now or is
that into DJ's issue I think the key
piece for me is that
um whether it's the entity or whether
it's Council it's the community's
problem
um and so we want to make sure that
regardless of whether we stay in the
driver's seat or somebody else does that
we put the community
um in the best position to succeed the
other pieces with the uncertainty around
water reform I think we'd want to make
sure that we don't make any decisions at
the moment that we can't live with
because we simply don't know at the
moment which direction this is going to
go in and the third piece being that
um
you'll you'll potentially be aware that
when you talk about
um big central government agencies that
they don't tend to invest in anything
without a pretty significant business
case that's been run to back that up
that's something that invercargills
um got a lower level I guess of maturity
in that space we don't do a lot of those
big chunky business cases we're
conscious that we need to do that around
these ones because our best chance of
making sure that these projects get to
the front of the line is to have all of
that business casing work done and
dusted and these projects well Justified
and and ready to go gives them the best
chance that when the entity does hand
over that they're able to deliver them
efficiently for the community so the
community doesn't wind up well just just
to get the answer I was after I just
want to know that obviously New Plymouth
they've got 41 hectares put aside
they've obviously got a consent for it
now the consenting process to actually
if you did find land
the RMA process to actually get that
obviously you've got neighbors that are
going to be around this land now what
time period seriously would doing it
take I mean you know if you start doing
this you've got to find the land you've
got to try and get consent and I think
it's 2029 is going to come real quick
and you can't be reactionary in 2029 so
are we looking at buying land have we
done that now I mean we should have we
should have looked at possible land by
now because if you're raising this
concern now we should have done this
hang on we haven't just come back from
the things remember the start of the
workshop was about
we're not trying to make decisions here
it's just no no no but Aaron's just
raised she's escalated but so for me and
I'll come to you in a minute knowing but
I think
you know the important thing to remember
I believe is that you know the whole
country is moving away from a very
traditional historic method of get it
out there into water as quickly as you
can right
to a very different approach which is a
better more acceptable way of dealing
with waste which is disturbs to land
right so and you've highlighted the
taranaki and I think Timaru might be
going through a similar thing you know
that they're leaning into some of those
conversations now for for my perspective
I think
then I pick up Aaron's
comment about the maturity I think as a
country air maturity around how we do
this and the most effective and
efficient way to do this which is a very
new model will evolve quite quickly and
so there's risk with us sort of Leaning
into it too soon because the
understanding around how best to do it
and how it'll look and that sort of
thing and the reality is there's a fair
bit of pressure if it goes into a
centrally organized entity for that
energy to solve this problem because
it's well recognized that discharged
water is is a burning brochure so you
know I think there's a level of
collectivism where everyone's going to
be trying to solve this problem we you
don't want to be sort of an early
starter on this but that's only my
perspective you've got to be aware of it
and and be perhaps assessing some
options but you don't hit it's not a
problem we have to solve because of
what's going to change around the whole
country's going to be moving to
discharge to land and that will happen
in the next 10 10 years yeah I think
you're right in that it's definitely an
emerging area and we we don't have
Clarity yet that it's definitely going
to be one way or it's definitely going
to be the other way I am aware of
councils that are working through
options at the moment where they are
looking very likely to get consents
through to still go to water
um with high level treatment provided as
an option so
um at this stage I don't think it's
absolutely off the table the team have
definitely done work going back some
years around potential areas of of land
that could be looked set for disposal at
least one of those already being in
council's ownership
but we obviously need to work through
the detail of what that would actually
look like and that's a negotiation
process with ewe with regional councils
with a whole range of different
stakeholders as well as a whole lot of
uh very smart design people input from
the team to come up with what is our
best option going forward we're
definitely underway with it but we we
need to keep it moving at PACE yeah and
sober is the best way for us to you know
to
assist that strategic risk is to be a
very active Observer of some of those
things that are happening if it's in
taranaki or if it's someone that's gets
a consent to go to water and the level
of investment because that informs their
decision
you know and again it's probably to my
point if if you're at the front of there
trying to solve that problem too soon
it's going to incur a lot of costs that
might then get pushed one way or the
other through regulation or change in
technology whatever so you're better off
to be close to the front of the race but
be observing what's happening at the
front of the race if that makes sense
yeah and there's definitely you're
you're absolutely right
um where the The Balancing Act for us is
that we're now getting to the point
where we're running out of time in that
we need to start constructing something
in a few years time so we do need to
very much take those learnings that have
happened around the country we've
engaged some people to work with us
through that who have been involved in
multiple different projects and so
um are aware of what's getting across
the line and what's not getting across
the line
um and leveraging that expertise to get
the best options on the table that we're
likely to get get through so to loop
back to your point really you know I
what I'm starting to land in my mind is
we we sort of do some sort of strategic
analysis as around as discharge the land
best for us and then how would that
problem be solved for us or is
discharged to water sorry chair and look
we're being told sorry I've been told in
Council that with getting consent the
chance is is basically zero because to
get consent from ewe it's not to do with
whether the quality of the water that's
being discharged it's actually where the
water has originated from as in yeah
yeah so it doesn't matter you could have
the water that clean turn it into
sparkling water and sell it and you
still couldn't discharge it yeah so the
up the chances of getting consent
zero yeah so why aren't that you know
but that that's to my point where so
that's something that has to be solved
right because if the belief is at a high
level that discharge the land is better
for whatever reason but you've got this
we've been told that we're looking at
extra treatment now why would we treat
it if if we already know that ewe will
not give consent
because of the where the waters come
from I mean we've been told that in
committee
have we we're we are looking we will be
exploring all options with with ewe and
other stakeholders that we've already
been told so I look I hate being told
one thing and then it changes I think
one of the one of the key
s with with these Journeys is that you
you don't start with the solution and
then take it take it to your
stakeholders it's very much around
building that solution together and and
that's the process that we're we're just
kicking off underway we've had some good
conversations over the last
um three or four months with tail marima
we've had them out to the treatment
plants
um and then we've got a essentially a
program manager on board in a similar
way to what we have Lee butcher running
now build it projects
um we've got somebody on board who's
managing that what are we going to do
program across these various different
consent pieces
just the discussion is good but at
highlights the fact that there's a lot
of risk in running really hard at this
early and we've just you know we're just
as much as we feel you know we've made
this a day that I would I think what
we've got to say is look let's just step
quietly forward be very informed about
the decisions we're making
and and keep a very observational role
it's really hard to be a player in the
game when when you don't know what the
rules are and someone keeps changing the
rules sorry so that means exactly to my
point you just if you don't know where
the writing course is going to finish
you don't go to the front and hit up the
wrong street you stay back at the pack
let someone else got the wrong streak
when the judges say no you're going left
you hit left
you're identifying the Rusk around you
can't be at the front of the race
um just just let me have something about
them um
I think we just need to earn on a little
bit of caution here and we'll we're
looking to Solutions so we would uh
Aaron talk about land or water discharge
but we have other options as well so for
argument's sake if the hydrogen plant
comes around and everything's looking
Rosy at the moment but there's a big if
the hydrogen part comes around it needs
water that's right but it does not need
treated water it can take a pot of water
now they said to me we could probably
take all your discharge water the whole
lot
so that's another thing that we haven't
we haven't picked up so I I guess I'm
just hearing on a bit of caution one if
the election comes round and it's not
the current government the position of
act and National has been they will
scrap the three Waters uh legislation
with the exception of the water quality
Bill and with the exception of the
monitoring agencies though the entities
will disappear and we will be back to
what do we do so we need to be
considering that as we go forward
because for National quite rightly they
say the issue is not with it
um ta should deliver their own which
they they're passionate about the real
issue is the funding yeah and whichever
model you're using either the taxpayer
or the right payer or a combination
thereof are going to pay for this
whichever way you go so why dismantle
what's a good process so I guess that's
the the first thing is and the other
thing that's not in our mind setting but
probably needs to be is
um is the issue of water meters and so
our water meters are an important thing
uh for two reasons one they reduce the
demand of the front end for fresh water
and so given our current freshwater
Supply in being at risk with just having
one source and if we ever wanted to
reduce what goes out the other end and
it could be a combination of water
meters and data banks slash hydrogen
plants may take out pod water we may not
need to worry about where we discharge
it 100 so you know there's there's some
potential there but we just need to sit
and wait to see if there's some of the
stuff pans one of the other advantages
of water meters as they can help us
identify where there are holes in our
infrastructure well that's that's one of
the things I was going to flag but later
on with is that
um I'm not talking about Auckland but um
certainly uh Central's got water meters
in and and I think it's widely known and
there's more exports in the room than me
say that you lose about 30 of your water
through the pipe system if you don't
have water meters if you do have water
meters you can detect where they are
very quickly and so
um it gives you two things one it gives
you
um less pumped in you don't need so much
so you save 30 but you also see where
the weaknesses are because obviously it
leak's a weakness and it gets ahead of
potential something's a bit more
catastrophic so yeah
um but they want to meet those are
initially unpopular Trish
um strategically I think we need to
consider things like the consents to
keep them moving we want to be business
ready so that if we do go into an entity
or whatever we need to make sure that
they are a priority to keep checking
them along so that we're getting closer
to where we want to be
okay so if we just if
be with me a little bit and I'm going to
show you some of the numbers shortly and
I think some of those things are are
going to um well what what you might do
for us is just hold there and have a
sort of 10 minute break
from Mornington toilet and then come
back to this I thought you might be
better to see the numbers before then
okay
it depends on the numbers we could all
be crying in the toilet
so we'll break and we'll be back at
quarter past shopping
whatever
I remember
okay obviously
so welcome back
um
to the
sorry Mr chair I'll just go through the
rest of these delivery projects so we've
got you know future
um projects about the water intake at
Banks home we've talked a little bit
about
um the timing of what we need in Bluff
and how do we create it I think there's
obviously a piece of work that we have
to understand where our city will
develop over the next five 10 or 30
years and actually understand where
infrastructure needs to either lead that
development or follow it I guess that's
the challenge of and that's the future
that ties up with the district plan
and we just need to continue to keep a
good eye on what our health and safety
implications are
these projects are about I guess being
ready for some of those things so
um understanding whether you know
Financial contributions are something
for new developments there are places
where
um
people the developers may have to
supplement
um
input Capital into into some of the
works that we need for instance if the
water Network's not capable everywhere
then if we have to improve it to make
sure they can subdivide land then that's
something we need to have a discussion
about
we need to as I've discussed earlier we
need to make sure our models are are up
to date so that we can actually
demonstrate if we put a subdivision in a
big subdivision in one place what does
it do to the network so it operates
satisfactorily
and our Overland
um modeling with a big rainfall where
does the water go and make sure we know
it's going to happen
and once again it's this how do we plan
ahead for some of the numbers that we've
got for the project deliveries
all right so this really just highlights
our current operational budget but um I
think the real interesting thing is this
next slide that we've popped into there
so we've pulled the projects that we
have we'll have them I guess the bids
process going forward into a timeline
and this is a reason me
um unconstrained This Is Us saying these
are all the things that we would like to
do if we could do them timing maybe a
little bit um
needs to be Revisited but when you see
some of those numbers those numbers
start to grow really quite
large there's some big numbers in there
and I'll just move on to the next slide
so that's what the numbers are looking
like we're proposing to want to spin
across the three asset areas so
whereas numbers become quite
significant in the first few years so
there's big Peaks really on and that
might well be that we're the options
that we that you will need to actually
work through saying which ones these are
our most important assets we need to do
which ones can we push out a little bit
further and what's the consequence of
doing that so
that's what we currently will have in
the
um it's in our forecasting for it to our
finance team for them to bring back as
part of the that budget pack that you
will get as part of the ltp so those
numbers are reasonably significant you
know each of them are running early on
between you know
storage and water and some of those
numbers and 40s which is a huge ask for
the
to be a be ready and B for contractors
to be able to deliver those successfully
for us so so the timing might be a
little bit early but um it's the big
numbers but and Russell that still has
um upgrade of capacity to Bluff sitting
quite a way out if we pulled that
forward we'd have an even greater Peak
early correct yep are you have you
summarize the assumptions those
forecasts are based on
slides yeah not in the slides yeah it
would be useful to see those
so what I've tried to do is from the
budget pack that we Finance colleagues
have developed I grabbed the first five
years and the teacher isn't necessarily
to read them individually but it
actually just starts to look like
there's something like over the next
five years
including BAU for our pipe renewals this
sort of 300 million dollars being
currently suggested
that's the eso that's quite a lot and
you know you can see the um the greens
are there
sewage and then the blues of the water
so you can say by disc by numbers and I
just
went through and took any project that
was over a couple million dollars and
put onto the table rather than
necessarily take them all so the List's
reasonably big but it's really just the
intention to do that and you've got um
lots of
things to occur in those times so but
there are allowances for specific things
that have got some big numbers that are
currently assigned as a starting
position I guess that's
I think the other thing I'd just speak
clear honors as much as these are big
chunky numbers the majority of these
numbers were foreseen
um prior to the last long term plan
which means that when we did our
analysis of whether or not ICC felt that
we would be better off under a three
Waters entity model or under a go It
Alone model we had factored the majority
of these big chunky costs into that that
model which still showed that lower cost
of ICC
staying alone with the assets
what's the significance of the color
coding it's just so you can see the
difference of the asset group so all
right that's that's made it easy if
someone asked me about a Wastewater I
could focus on my table a little bit
better so
but I guess that's the
the live that's the uh or expectation of
what we think those costs are going to
look like and that's part of it will be
part of the forecast in budget packs
just going through like the we don't the
levels of service in terms of the BAU
we can
we will continue to use the same kpis
over the next two year period is what is
what we've been suggested by the NTU
and one of the slides we need we have
all talked about is how do we actually
maintain this compliance Zone and we've
talked about the uh the stage consents
we need to work continue at PACE to keep
those things that can't be something we
let rest that's something we've got to
keep pushing along at um
we need to do some work certainly in the
water network security which includes
some back backfire prevention
um we need to build a water filling
station so where's we uh so with water
tankers fill up at the moment it's uh
needs to be improved and when you do
ongoing testing
to my understanding and my colleagues
over here we don't currently have a
water meter budget included in their
bids process
good okay Alistar tells me we do
and we've done that as a a two-stage as
I recall Alistair one around essentially
Network Readiness and then the second
piece around actually a roll out of of
meters
but it could be spread over more than
one year
let's see Austin
um so one of the things that we really
do want to make sure is that we don't
have any unexpected failures and I guess
that's really why one of our projects we
highlighted was the mersey street um
Rising main it's one of those Mains that
is something that we carefully maintain
and something that we need to pull
forward and it's a pretty significant
piece of work that we need to program
and as we've talked a little bit about
um from a compliance
what an expectation is that the Auckland
rainfall event is something that no
network in New Zealand or I would expect
would actually be able to easily manage
as a whole of network so there's a whole
lot of challenges and in that space if
we get a really really high rainfall of
insight
obviously the list of things that we're
suggesting looks to lift that level of
service and looks to I guess increase
our
level of resilience
at Chicago to go forward that's really
the level of investment that we're
looking to do to say we are ready for
the future
obviously to how we improve our water
quality is one of those things that we
have to continue to to work on
and the proposal the proposed bids have
a range of I guess options for for
odatara and Bluff and those are the some
of those options that you will be able
to consider
actually just right there so what I've
put here is when you're considering the
options which will be
um I guess part of your your ltp process
tried to list some of the things that
are that could be helpful when you and
your decision making process over and
above you so just thinking about what
you know what is how is your Strategic
investment you know when is it the right
time to do it or is it the right
priority you know
about criticality about failure risk you
know how important is it to you in the
wider sense
does it align with what your The
council's Wider desire for housing and
spatial planning because if there are
plans for the spatial plan to grow in
somewhere do we have a network that
actually mirrors that and actually
supports that
um what happens if with the legislative
requirements of how high in the priority
would that give you and what does it do
to health and safety so
foreign
really sorry is about projects um
ideally
um
we could have options inside of those
but most of the things that we've got
have a project
focus in the Capital Area
just on the um
within your critically failure risk
category that would be
um you know significant impact on
service you're classifying that in there
absolutely so we've got a number of the
rising Mains that are single Rising
Mains that's in pumped sewer Mains
around the city and if they fail or have
some outage through either a pump
station or a pipe failure then we have
quite a significant problem because
that's the way the nature of the Beast
Works having some duplication or having
some ability to actually reduce that
risk is actually what we're looking for
in all those projects so those those one
to five aren't in the order of
importance they just listed now I've
just highlighted those because I think
part of you your framework where you'll
have to consider all your projects
across Council um from an
infrastructural perspective of that the
sorts of things that we would want to
encourage you to also have a view over
yeah because I think that's an important
this Matrix to help counselors decide is
you know ranking what is the highest
priority so
if I hit a cricketer I'd you know at the
top would be critical failure risk and
probably religious sort of
risk
um you know and then you know coming
down and I think that's important to
help us make decisions from a governance
level as as
what is the most important thing we need
to address
it's just trying to refresh
those things that are um
in the in the thinking process really
um the framework which Rhiannon has for
all the bids has a whole lot of those
but it's just I guess expressed a little
bit differently and aligned more
particularly about the options that
we're offering in terms of the
infrastructure world so so just to that
point
and following on some feedback we got
from Andrew a wee while ago around you
know
we don't assess risk properly when we
put our papers forward to council
that's the sort of stuff we should be
seeing in terms of how the particular
decision that's been considered
addresses those relationship to these
decisions right so that's the sort of
stuff we should start to see in those
papers I think uh probably rhiannon's
framework around how we assess all of
these together is probably the best way
to address that Rihanna
correct yeah so just to
um remind the councilors that the
framework that you adopted a few months
ago is what the asset and activity
managers are using in preparing their
asset and activity plans for you and
that structure includes the Strategic
aspects that Russell's listed here at
the top of their
um of his slide but also the aspects
around is the change needed because of
legislative or health and safety risk or
is it needed because of changing demand
so you'll receive those as
assessments yeah but what I'm meaning is
when we receive our papers for Council
we've always got a piece which assesses
the risk
are we going to get be seeing this sort
of stuff in there more specifically than
we've probably seen in the past which
has generally been a general statement
around the riskers visible there yes
sorry so if my answer wasn't very clear
yes it will be within the framework that
you've adopted in terms of that risk is
it's clearly there in terms of the story
and the paper writer will address those
yes things in the paper yes
I I think there's a piece there just
around um to Andrew's point that Council
does have in place a a risk framework
um there is work and I don't know
whether Michael wants to make a comment
but there is work around developing our
maturity in that space and you're
absolutely right there would there's
definitely room for us to bring
um better uh risk assessment into the
council papers and I think you'll see it
in some papers where we're really seeing
chunky risk but we need to bring it more
into the BAU papers as well I agree
linking back to these tops criteria
slide is really I guess just trying to
pull some of the themes that we're
seeing like consenting which we've
talked about
um the opportunities and I guess the
risk mitigation of an alternative slash
emergency water supply
and how those connections from
potentially our
into invercargill how to how does it
help Bluff Supply and how does it happen
for kogel some of those key high level
things
we talked about the high risk vessel
Mains and that's really is a thing that
keeps some of our technical people awake
at night
um without having really good modeling
and future Asset Management
decisions become harder and harder the
sites while we're looking to invest in
that I guess that's more in that
planning phase rather than in the big
numbers and once again the resilience
issue is something that we shouldn't
keep too far away from our minds
so I've just popped that table on there
so that
um which is hopefully what the dean has
got to be able to circulate so as
councilors like in the previous
workshops you can go through and
right whether you like them or dislike
them
so that going forward you have the
opportunity when they come up you can
help us as we write our plans going
forward
not necessarily going to dwell too much
on the kpis because the kpis will remain
the same I know I had a brief look and I
think when you'll read your annual plan
that the performance of the networks
from the teams is pretty good they're
mostly green across the kpi performances
so that's pretty positive but once again
the interview is suggesting that uh we
don't necessarily have to consult on the
kpis because
um they will be what you've we've used
in the past so I think for the other
piece just is worth that they've very
much aligned to the Department of
internal affairs um kpis that are set
nationally which we have to report on
anyway
um so we've already got some fairly
clear guidance there
so we'll just
skip through some of those but hopefully
the things that you will be seeing in
your quarterly reports and being the
things that you'll start to be able to
ask questions on as you do that normally
I'm often in the asset plans we'd have
lots of words but in this case we've got
one very brief paragraph So what we've
currently our position is is that the NT
or entity J is developing an asset plan
for everybody that's part of their
correction and they have suggested two
councils that you can rather than write
your own Asset Management plan for the
three Waters you can use their Asset
Management plan and place an addendum in
that plan
which is the invercargill flavor and
therefore present that to order
as part of the ltp process so that
actually helps us having to go through a
full documentation pathway for the three
three Waters of three plans
um that would hope be hopeful that it
will actually reduce here I guess our
overheads that's one of the areas that
we don't we haven't necessarily got lots
of resource
um we haven't necessarily resourced up
in that area given that
the past has been at the entity is going
to be formed and therefore having staff
recruiting in the markets near
impossible in that space anyway so
that's what we'll see is it will be an
entity standard plan and we're proposing
it we'll just detect our addendum which
will be our information anyway it's
about their assets and those sorts of
things so
um I think it's probably just worthwhile
noting that all although we have
indicated that to the NTU We Believe
there'll be significant pressure on them
in that space and so we may have to
change the tact if we feel that that's
not going to provide the right outcome
for us so we'll keep a close watching
brief on that
so my last slide really just tries to
pull together some of these things so
um would you know the three Waters
assets that we have across councils are
some of the most important assets that
we do have
the affordable Waters reform um will
will take some form it'll either be
where it's going or go somewhere
different and I guess October will be a
good time to start to keep watching that
space
what we've shown today is that we do
need to make sure we continue to
strengthen our relationship with ewe
because some of those decisions going
forward are absolutely key for both
we and the community and how we work how
we understand a what the available
options are for us going forward
the council has some opportunity
um to carefully guide where your
investment level where you want to
invest in and why and working working
through that has actually may take a
couple of iterations from my perspective
just making sure you know what you're
gonna know why you're doing it and what
the and what you're trying to achieve
rather than necessarily purely looking
at the at the project because sometimes
what you want to achieve might not
necessarily be the actual project you
might want to have a different outcome
um they are significant projects and
there's still lots of work to do we just
can't sit and wait for them to happen
because they'll happen because we need
lots of um the right people doing things
I think there are some opportunities for
some of the options to be timed a little
bit different but I guess that's our
first cut we need to where we start
during this process whatever happens in
the three Waters or the affordable
Waters World
um
we have to manage both their staff
knowledge about how do we transfer
knowledge and how do we make sure that
we actually have those right people
across all of our business including our
contractors doing the right thing for us
because there's immense pressure on that
resource out there
um
and the team does remarkably well to get
the right people doing the right things
and I guess that's reflected in that we
have um you know pretty pretty
successful kpis
we've got excellent knowledge
but you've also got to think to the
Future about how do we retain that
knowledge and where do we go so change
is quite a
dramatic thing for someone for some of
the team and it will impact them quite a
lot
um and the key discharge consents are
things that I've had quite a range of
discussion on and how important they are
to get going to actually think through
what it is we want to do and actually
keep progressing and and some of that is
actually good conversation good
relationships but it's also making sure
we've got the right level of resource
and skilled resource to be able to
progress that
but overall I think what I would like to
suggest to you is that the wider team
does a pretty good job looking after our
systems and our systems through councils
I guess investment over time this seem
to be in pretty good health you know I
think we're not in that place where
we've um it's not we're not getting
ahead of ourselves but it's not
running from behind and catching us so I
think ever on an overall perspective
we're seeing to be pretty successful in
that space But that's
a good opportunity for for what
invercargill as a whole to be ready for
the future
happy to take further questions yeah
Trish
um in terms of strengthening Evie
connections and relationships do are you
will you consider outside our local one
it's like you know if we're going to be
in the entity well is it would it be
worthwhile trying to strengthen those
beforehand
as well or what you're thinking around
that
so I understand that um Michael's
already having some discussions in that
space just to make sure particularly
with the affordable water conversation
that you know we know what everybody's
thinking our position is clear and that
we're just having some some open
Communication in that space at the
moment so absolutely something that we
want to continue to do yeah because
it'll be too late when it's done yeah
I've got one just around your
opportunities for cost savings are in
contract efficiencies
um and I know you and you and I have had
this conversation around
how our contracts are
developed with air
service providers
so myself yeah right you go it's
one that Russell Cain will probably have
a little smirk about because we're
having some pretty chunky conversations
about that at the moment
um our existing three Waters contract
was due to expire prior to the previous
time frame for us to move into the new
entities we're now in a process where we
said we wouldn't extend that for 12
months and negotiate a new contract that
got us into the new entity period and
we're just having to have a look at
whether we've got the date right on that
now depending on on which way reform
goes and if it goes
um at the moment the the contract we
have is very much a a traditional
contract where we're paying for really
what we we need and I would suggest not
a lot more
um
happy if Russell wants to jump in on any
of these ones one of the the
conversations I've been having with
Russell is a hobbit surely we want a
contract that is is smarter where our
contractors are challenging us some more
where they're bringing value nationally
um and what Russell's wonderfully said
to me is the but we also need to look at
what's the problem we're trying to solve
in that we've actually got a network
that performs really really well
um I I sort of went oh yes but are we
intervening at the right place if we're
a bit smarter we might you know save
some money and but we've actually got
one of the lowest debt costs in the
country against our assets so I guess in
in from a Contracting perspective where
we're not doing it flashy we're just
doing the basics but we're making sure
we do the basics really well
um we're talking to our contractors at
the moment around if we changed the
model what might that look like how
could we find efficiencies and they're
basically telling us that the model
you're on is about as efficient as it's
going to get any other model is going to
potentially come with some different
benefits but is going to come with more
cost as well so we're not finished in
that space at the moment and we're
talking uh and planning to go up and do
a trip to the top of the South Island to
talk to some other councils that have
made changes in that space and how it's
gone for them
um but at the the moment the team are
doing actually a pretty good job of
convincing me that we've probably got
this about right yeah I suppose my
thinking is that
historically you know it's been about
discovering the cheapest price
and
I think probably there's a a different
approach which can leverage off the
skill set that the potential contract
Partners can bring and so we get a
really effective outcome yeah and so we
look at the outcome not price as the
driver and then who is best to partner
with and then a process of of
discovering who that partner is
goes through a model that perhaps is
being used in some other areas
of our business
um so we we end up with a real true
partnership because the feedback I get
from the contractors and from
infrastructure new zealanders it's a
win-lose master servant relationship
about best cost and it's not
it's not the best way forward in terms
of the outcome and I think there's a
piece there that we need to still work
through around yes our networks
performing pretty well on that model
um we're generally reasonably happy on
that model but there's a piece around
the broader industry and what's actually
best at keeping the broader industry
strong and do we need to pay a bit more
to do our part yeah in that space and
it's a really good point and if you look
at probably the infrastructure industry
you know in there no different in the
other industry where they had lots of
resources and people and capital was
quite cheap and so they could sort of
expect their business as well now
they're trying to be as efficient as
they possibly can and don't want any
more stuff than they need and use a lot
more subcontractor so their business
model has evolved which means in my view
it puts a lot of pressure on their
ability to deliver outcome in an
effective way consistent with contract
and and look to you know in in defense
of the Contracting networks across all
of our Industries I think they you know
they actually give Council in some ways
a bit of an easy run in the their their
costs are escalating out of sight and
yet they we're not seeing that passed on
to us it does mean though as you say
they're trying to spread what they've
got thinner and thinner and thinner and
is that necessarily the space that we
want the industry to go into well we may
not be seeing it in the tender price but
we will see it through the contract
agree there's the risk
yeah okay didn't wake anyone else up so
that's right
any other questions
well Russell you owe me 15 minutes
because I've got you at a quarter 11
o'clock
yeah
15 minutes in yeah I'll just take a
couple of minutes of the 15. um
again just to reinforce I think that we
we need a tread lightly till we get to
October which is not far away
um because if we are no longer to have
entities
um that will change the landscape for us
um and also it'll be interesting to see
whether if we do get a change of
government where they'll go on the
amalgamation of councils as well which
is
um encompasses three Waters but it
actually is much wider than that yeah I
think it would be my overall view uh
given that I've got 200 years left that
on either of those two counts that we
would be better to stand alone our track
record of such that amalgamating with
other councils for the greater good of
New Zealand Inc or Southland Inc is not
in the best interest of our ratepayers
which is what we're primarily here for
so I think
a couple of months from now we'll get a
clear steer on that
um
the other issue is if we do end up with
a current government with the same or
different partners
um what do we do in that two-year
framework that we have so one of the
issues I guess would be that we need to
get some work done and done quickly
um so for fragments so if we didn't do
our alternative water supply and our
increased capacity to Bluff which future
proofs Edibles should take new new
Industries
those two combined around about 100
million dollars if we don't do that
um
then which I would suggest we would do
quickly because what that does is it
loads up our debt going to the system
where most of the other big players are
going to need to DJ have already got
significant debt so from so we've got 14
million dollars give or take a bit of
change on our Network
Queenstown Lakes District that is
smaller than us it's got 160 million
till we balance that out our rate paths
are going to be disadvantaged if we
leave it and and I ask the entity to
um
to prioritize that later on we will be
behind other priorities
um growth in in Queenstown Lake
districts
um climate change in South Indian issues
like that so we may not get that
alternative Water Supplies quickly as we
actually need it given that we've got
drought conditions
um the other benefit I do see is that
um
within the within the entities here we
have quite a large voting power with
their one for one relationship
that can work in our advantage but it
can work in our disadvantage and that's
one of the things that we will need to
sell because when you listen to
nighttime talking at the tuckyware level
and they say their priorities are in two
areas they've got other priorities but
two of the areas I have to deliver
better quality water and Water Systems
to areas of high deprivation for their
own people so and they quote the oh high
Knight caps and the materials and places
like that which is fine and they're also
very passionate about climate change
that could leave us out of the equation
unless we push for our deprivation level
in South City which is this all night
because one of the things about the
regional pictures
they look in the car and see it as quite
a wealthy area because of our farming
sector that's around us and that we do
okay where in fact actually we've got a
pocket in certainly South City and they
could possibly include Bluff as well
which is nine or ten decimals so the
figures say that
people live on the south side of their
City are
within the most deprived 200 000
households in the country and that's
something we sometimes lose sight of so
if we go forward on that model we'll
have we'll have to pipset to make sure
that we get ewe buying on on that
equation as well yeah okay
thank you Russell and thank you Russell
thank you yeah 10 minutes pretending so
appreciate it and very good pack too
thank you
it would it would be interesting to know
um Aaron if we if we could do some
background and work on on the potential
for water meters like how much would
they actually cost I know they're not
popular with about half the population
I'm very popular with the other half and
so that
like some council members nervous to be
isolating that that volume of Voters I
guess but I understand from Central it
only cost about
um two million to put in yeah and I know
alistair's done that work I don't know
that you have the figure off the top of
you no not Alistair but you've
definitely done the work around reality
we do have an allocation in the budget
so it's been put in front of you 7.9
million and it's been programmed rather
arbitrarily towards the end of this
decade if we do yeah because I know in
the central situation Tim Logan did say
to me they recovered that money they put
in I can't remember they said 10 or two
but whatever money they put in to put
the water means we were covered in just
two years and the really interesting
thing about the codc experience was the
question of whether or not simply having
meters in place but not charging for
them would drive down usage and and
there was the thought that if people saw
how much they were using that would have
at least some impact to drive down
demand what they found was that they
didn't charge I think for the first year
it pretty much had no impact whatsoever
and then the moment they turned the
charging on there was that about 30 drop
it was significant
um so it definitely is tied to that Hip
Pocket the demand piece and the ability
to sold the leaks absolutely yeah
yeah
okay thank you yeah
no you owe me five minutes
okay next up we've got
um housing so Heather Andrea and
Patricia
[Applause]
thank you Cheerio calculus
welcome
[Music]
um you'll notice from the first slide on
the actual start we have
called it elderly persons housing
because we are primarily
um invested in elderly persons we do
have some tenants who
um
uh younger than that
um with different
capabilities but going forward
we are primarily looking at elderly and
criteria as for 60 persons and older so
we are proposing to re
name the housing activity elderly
persons
um housing sorry that is why the first
slide look um doesn't just say housing
anyway going forward
um obviously provision of affordable
housing career early
um
as I said in the past we had a period
when demand was low and Council
increased the scope for tenants
here with the current demands suggested
the activity should be
renamed early housing which is a true
reflection of the nature of the activity
as it is now
uh we currently have the stock of 215
units
um and uh on a program to increase that
housing stock
with the addition of the four new units
that have been commenced at Stewart
Street and we're investigating viability
of lean stocks to for the next build as
part of the program
strategic priorities
pretty much as they are the changing
needs of their population which is
growing older and more diverse
um enabling the housing
um that needs to grow within the city
and maintaining their affordability for
attendance
and just um you know we've got the
challenges are increasing demand
and
aligning that stakeholder expectation
with their operational plans
the Aging of the assets and existing
financial model is currently not
self-funding I'll explain a bit more
about that in the future
the current budget shows operational
um
Revenue
with increased depreciation
due to higher values of property uh
there is a difficult deficit in their
operational Budget on those figures and
that currently also does not include the
capital program
in terms of maintaining levels of
service
um we have an increasing stakeholder
demand we have an increasing need for
attendance the recent media report from
presbyterian Support Services has
highlighted that they are just
establishing the
rental units
they had 50 they've got 25 that will be
um
they'll need to re-home those tenants
for before the end of the 12 months so
25 of those units have already been
vacated
um
unfortunately our current waiting list
is 18 months to two years which means
that an additional 25 potential tenants
would significantly increase that
waiting list
we are already getting
um
requests from those tenants from
presbyterian sport services
um to go on to our waiting list now
uh also in terms of maintaining levels
of service there's the impacts of
inflation and contractor availability
um
and the legislative changes that we've
that that can happen we've already done
most of those legislative changes that's
relation to the heating and ventilation
increasing that
maintain that level
sorry do you want questions through all
the at the end uh if you wish to take
questions three sorry yeah yeah just a
quick question what the Presbyterian
support reducing the number of units of
Peace Haven are there applications to
transfer over to us for a specific area
or are they going we'll go with there
are gaps
um
they would have to come in at the moment
they would have to come into the bottom
of their waiting list we can't
and put them ahead of someone else who's
currently in the waiting list so
yeah
they they it would be seen as being
someone else
uh who already is in a situation that
got the they've got a
they're sitting in a in a an ability
where they can't pay now or they have no
sorry I understand that so therefore if
they were saying we wanted to go and do
a specific area they'd have to join the
bottom of the waiting list for that area
yes we don't actually do that so at the
moment our waiting list is that if they
they would once they reach the top and
we have a unit that comes available if
it's not if they get off at the unit if
they don't want that unit they stay at
the top but we take the next person down
thank you
in a set list organized on Purely date
of Entry or is it need it's on date of
Entry so no consideration for need
no
yeah it could be if there was a
direction that that's what the way
councilors would want to go
yes it is yeah what
what was priority in terms of bringing
them on the waiting list and it's just
date yes
um
maintaining compliance is pretty much
space that's basically in legislation
driven
um it's in terms of healthy homes
standards
um we do regular
inspections in terms of any asbestos we
have some
flooring coverings
that when they are due for replacement
or have some issues with them we will
replace those asbestos based ones and we
have a
um asbestos management process in place
for any exterior
covering um clearings that might have
um
need penetration in terms of
maintenance work on there
savings and additional Revenue
sorry these are the
SE these are the the bits where we might
have some questions so potentially
um
opportunities for cost savings or
additional rental Revenue um we could be
changing a rental structure to move
close to our Market rental
um that would have an impact currently
on our current tenants obviously
and any future tenants in regards to
affordability
they are
the the rentals we've got now uh
uh low but they are very low income
and low asset tenants
uh partnership opportunities
um
or disposal would also have an impact on
the current of future tenants
not only in regards to affordability but
also potentially in relation to
eligibility
um
World community housing provider will
attract benefits for rental reduction
they also might have a different
criteria
for eligibility which our current
tenants may not necessarily meet or
which may lengthen the waiting list for
a future tenants
sorry Josh
um the people who are in the older
units that were established say 1950s
um where did they sit in regard to the
waiting list
so you said that there's only it comes
in when
um the waiting list is based on a date
so say
um
say somebody's sitting in one of those
units and they've decided if you've
decided we've decided that they need to
be replaced
how do they where do they fit so we
would find so we wouldn't
we wouldn't take them out of the unit
until we've got somewhere for them to go
right so does that mean
I'm just trying to get myself does that
mean that say there were 10 units
available
they would not be available to those on
the waiting they may not be available to
those on the waiting list they may be
available to the people who are being
replaced potentially yes yeah
so get it and further to that what
assessments done
of the need of the people that are
applying to the list
assessments and what way are you in
terms of their need
um
so when they apply
um they they say whether they're
currently in current housing or whether
they're if they're if then requiring
emergency housing we direct them to the
MSD for emergency housing assistance
because we aren't in a position to
provide that we certainly don't have
units just waiting for emergency housing
proposals
um it
most of the tenants that we have on the
waiting list are already in some form of
housing it's about affordability for a
lot of them right
okay and then so um
just in terms of the opportunities sorry
Grant oh sorry sorry I think I'll just
add to that because I think the question
you might have been asking was just
around how are you actually assessed as
being okay to go on the waiting list and
that is around the eligibility
criteria that we have in place and it
largely it comes down to those things
around your your current housing
situation your financial situation
um so there is a criteria that ABS
absolutely and everybody essentially
gets assessed and triaged against that
ahead of going on to the waiting list
yeah okay thank you
um so like on this opportunity of cost
savings
um
you know
I think you know we got quoted some
costs per square meter to build housing
which was quite a bit above what the
market rate is
and and then you look at the trend and
I'm thinking around the tiny house thing
that's being picked up quite strongly by
um people not necessarily who can't
afford but who are choosing to have a
different way of meeting their housing
need you know they may have a tiny house
on there
children's
adult Children's Place and they are the
yes best model and they might have two
or three of them instead of them having
one big palatial place in the mount
maunganui they might have two or three
tiny homes around the place that they
can move around the country and then a
camper van
yeah you know so what I'm probably
thinking is that as that type of housing
which is very affordable in terms of a
cost the type of housing that could come
into this provision for in the portfolio
mix
is a question to understand I think is
opposed to be answers it would be
suitable for some of the younger tenants
that are coming in younger isn't six
years so he's been considered or as on
the consideration list in terms of how
we provide for housing the majority of
the tenants that are actually applying
are in their and their 80s at the moment
right so steps and things and you're
unlimited so solutions that we have been
looking at have been more of a Universal
Design so that it would cater to yeah
um people as they age and also even the
people that are coming in when they are
in their 60s they're staying in their
homes a lot longer yeah than they ever
would do you know they're not going into
care as soon as they used to 30 years
ago yes
okay okay here just the the other piece
to add there is there you know there is
definitely the ability to provide
um elderly housing at a lower cost than
the ones that we are currently building
however we've assessed what the best
whole of Life value is in terms of how
long we want to actually keep that stock
in place and how frequently we have to
maintain it replace it uh Etc so that's
all fed into that that thinking as well
as to Andrea's Point around making
things that work for the widest variety
of of people so that we're not having to
keep going back in and changing the
facilities as as different needs of
people enter into those spaces yeah
yeah it did lock it it's a very evolving
market and you know it's less than a
thousand dollars a square meter to
provide a very good level in terms of
all your metrics around regulation
um so you know for more and I think it's
an option
yeah so I've got uh four developments
going on there but I'll wait till I
start to finish the area because it's
fall beyond what they're currently
providing right okay so
yeah a lot of movement at the moment
that's it I think probably what I'm
thinking is that how we've sort of
traditionally met the need is evolving
you know quite strongly both in the need
but equally the way to provide for it
and it's just the way we think about it
proper probably I'll come back to that
yeah
so in terms of uh proposals for
um levels of service
um we have uh drafted a housing policy
which will be brought through to council
for review
and approval within the next uh few
months
um
and that will set out
Direction in terms of
the the policies regarding eligibility
regarding
um how we uh looking at housing stocks
and things like that
um
we are also developing agreed uh quality
requirements for accessibility
for minimal levels of service including
handrails and accessibility
which would meet the changing needs and
demands of their tenants
and we're also reviewing
[Music]
um
when refurbishing and renewing units the
inclusion of new building standards and
what that might mean for us
there's also been
some funding provided to us obviously
through central government for
the opportunity for double glazing and
some minor accessibility processes which
will also give us some improved levels
of service within there
um
current buildings and of course we're
increasing our housing stock
um
so you expect
two units are improved with double
glazing and whatever else is needed does
the rate does the rent increase
that is not the proposal at this stage
yep there is a written increase on a
different yeah
question have we done it's probably
Patricia
have we done any modeling it's going on
back to the cost thing on the
the Capital Growth of the asset so we
can look at it and say there's a cost to
having this asset but equally I would
imagine that just the Capital Growth of
the asset through time with what's
happened with
um Capital values and cost we would have
had a gain in our SFA which would be in
line with Market roughly yes so they're
revalued to Market every at the same
time as we revalue all our other Landing
buildings yeah so there has been a
significant growth we have got a number
which are probably towards the end of
their
useful life
um because we they were built in the 50s
and yeah 60s some of those very early
ones are probably getting towards the
time where the improvements but the S
underlying land is better with yes yeah
be interesting to see that in some stage
yeah I'm just wondering what happens
what's happening with the people in the
old Grand building are they in this
project and that's a private emergency
alert cutting facility it's probably
owned oh yeah it's not it yeah it's
privately owned pattern government
tenants privately owned
you know we're only government people
have placed it you know there
funded to be their agencies
yeah emergency housing you use Excuse me
emergency housing which is it's a
privately owned asset which has got a
contract with government yeah which is
government funded yeah
not unlike some other sort of features
um I'll let Aaron speak to this
so this was just to Loop in what week um
have been working on in the background
around a proposal for central government
funding uh what this had looked at was
the potential for 100 new homes across
five years for elderly housing and what
it might take to achieve that we worked
up a proposal which was a joint ewe
Council partnership and we were looking
for or we still are looking for central
government to come into that partnership
what we have proposed is that if if
central government supported that the
council would commit funding over five
years to a total value of seven million
dollars that's slightly higher than what
we had in the previous long-term plan
and essentially would be us stepping up
our our commitment in line with central
government coming to the party to assist
us in that space
in addition to that seven million
Council would also provide the land and
we've proposed three potential sites for
that and that Council would also fund
the the infrastructure Connections in
lieu of development contributions
the requirement of funding from Council
from central government had been
proposed at uh 27 million dollars to
essentially make the dream happen
um and that we are still working to try
to see if we can find a way to get
within the central government criteria
and receive funding in that space
so what's the cost of project 50 million
it comes out I'm just recalling at about
high 30s about 38 million
um there's just a little bit of
um
a piece there around our land value
because essentially central government
usually looks to a 50 50 funding and
that can include the cash contribution
of council the land contribution of
council and the infrastructure
contribution of council uh what we've
proposed is that we don't want
invercargill to be disadvantaged because
of our lower land values so we've used
some national averages on land value as
to what that amount of land would be
valued at and proposed that back to
central government so that we do just
tip over into that 50 50 space of a
total of as I recall just under 40
million dollars total
so did the numbers stick up there if we
contribute 50 with land plus
infrastructure cost plus seven million
and they put in 27. and that that's what
I say it depends on how you value the
land Pace but the projects so if we if
we inflate our land value then it's a
higher it's a higher total project cost
oh
the um will the 27 million be alone
before we get a civil government no no
no so
so why then would you have a proposed
Council ewe central government you call
it partnership
the money's basically coming to council
yeah to do this development that's right
why then would you break it down and
have a proposed partnership because all
the income you know the rental income
wants these properties 100 properties
will come to council to
generate more property I cannot say I
think I've just used the term
partnership in acknowledging this it
would be a significant financial
contribution from central government
because you know
it wouldn't be an ongoing partnership
and central government to be part of
that because the council I mean here we
are part of council anyway uh so we
don't wouldn't need ewe and central
government to be part of it if we were
going to fund the 100 new homes just
fully by Council if we want Central
and so at this stage e we wouldn't be
putting in what they would be doing is
working with us around a a model to
support ewe outcomes and that is the
criteria that we are that's the correct
area that we're required to meet for the
central government
it needs to be a partnership with ewe to
qualify for central government funding
um because I was involved with this
um
they're not putting any money in now
um but to get the doors open you know
the way the government works at the
moment you've got to have Erie buying
um so
um we agreed that probably about
somewhere between 25 and 30 percent of
the houses that we might get that might
be targeted towards Erie given where
they sit in the social deprivation stats
that we have in their City
um so that was a way of getting the door
open
okay cool
so just a couple of car options for
Council to consider
um
the activity is forecast to continue to
cover its operating costs going forward
um however the Surplus is obviously not
enough to cover the cost of asset
renewal based on the current annual
depreciation
amount we have a considerable shortfall
um and
um
new renews around
um undertaken over the net debt account
for housing which will move into a
deficit going forward
uh diver deferring that renewal program
would also result in escalated renewal
costs for the future
um
and any new builds would increase the
cost the activity at the moment based on
figures
um of an estimated uh 38
000 per am per unit
which includes your depreciation your
cost of loan interest and the expected
operating
Surplus
um so
to balance that budget we should perhaps
consider rating for the shortfall
um during the next RTP process going
forward
um rather than passing this on in the
future
um
it's a big one to consider
um but it's out there so there's a piece
missing in that formula there wasn't
it's the appreciated asset value
the appreciated we're accounting for the
depreciation but not accounting for the
asset value increase
Patricia could you
can you repeat that again for me
we we're accounting for the depreciation
but we're not accounting for the asset
value or are we within that p l annually
we count
um within the activities p l we don't
because it's a bottom line it's an asset
okay so it's only
you can only realize it when you sell
the asset so it sits below the line
um yeah but but it's I mean I
however yes thank you continue on here
the depreciation when we're looking at
the op at the cost to run the activity
the depreciation is about though
um
doesn't well it it doesn't really come
into it
because as long as we can make the
operating cost up so the rent comes in
we can make the operating costs of
running it yeah
and we can fund
the renewal
so
this because you'd remember ever this
activity at present has no rates impact
at all
so we're trying to it's a
self-sustaining activity
so that the moment there's no rates
income going to it at all so it's
so we're looking at
and the question is whether we have to
look at a different way of doing it
which is what these guys have have
raised there's some those using
depreciation
we sort of take out of the
thing Michael's gonna
throw yourself chair uh fundamentally it
comes down to the capital in relation to
the housing and whether a council will
invest itself into the housing stock or
not so by Council investing in the
housing stock and and whether you get
the government investing as well that
takes the depreciation equation out of
the the mix
the housing needs to cover its operating
costs it's doing that and it's
contributing some um towards the capital
component
um the major change that's happened of
course is the value of the stock is
because you quite rightly pointed out
that's changed the equation slightly uh
what that changes is you need to rethink
about your funding mix from capital
investment so that's not about whether
you need to increase your operating
revenues and costs Etc it's about who's
contributing towards that Capital mix
and that's why we're looking at those
opportunities around government with the
100 100 homes component it's also we'll
need to have a honest conversation with
Council about how much this can Council
want to contribute in relation to that
because you it's not necessarily
required to put it onto the tenants from
that perspective you've got to have that
discussion as a council yeah it probably
leans a little bit in the discussion
around the re the um
share of the tech space doesn't it as
well because is it our duty to just fund
this need and air Community through our
rights or should central government
contribute is that proposing to do in
this instance but consistently through a
revenue sharing model
you can sort of get that happening
that'll be great thanks Miracle do her
best
oh yeah Darren he's got a question yeah
um
I kind of favor us maintaining the
status quo in that we focus on elderly
housing and
catering to the numbers that we do
currently but I also understand that in
order to do that we're going to have to
change and and digress my current policy
which is not to impose on rates to bring
the housing stock up the standard we're
going to have to do that and that's
really Our obligation as a landlord and
if by the way we're a city that rates
landlords who have the same expectation
on them from central government then we
need to be meeting that ourselves I am
incredibly hesitant about us moving into
these social housing need
um I don't see that as our
responsibility in local government at
all it is absolutely Central
government's responsibility and even in
a partnership form because it's just it
begins to be part of a divestment down
to us and once again every election term
will become The Whipping Boy of central
government and saying you know you keep
putting your rates up
um it's not good enough but we do that
because central government keeps
divesting responsibility for things down
to us so I think maintaining where we're
at with the housing stock but bringing
it up to being
fit for purpose
is where we should be and and it's going
to need some rates money and I'm
actually I'm okay with it
yeah the only thought I had there is the
is the moral obligation we have to
address all the needs of our community
yeah but shouldn't that sit with so
we've always been in that elderly
housing space yeah but the the welfare
of the broader Community outside of
infrastructure really sets with central
government
across successive governments they have
continued to let it down what why why
you know and I'm just sort of
trying to stimulate discussion here but
why why should we set aside or or
prioritize the elderly just because
we've done it in the past and
forego you know what is a huge need in
in social housing you know is it okay
for a young rangatahi to be brought up
in substandard housing yeah okay I don't
see that as fear
um and I'll use the the testing poll
that I always use of of the single
elderly woman in a one-bedroom unit in
Pomona Street who struggles to figure
out whether or not she can afford to
flick the heater on yeah and keep warm
at this time of the year yeah can we
justify to her that the rates go up to
help everybody else get into housing or
is that something that needs to be
serviced by central government and
that's where I'm coming home I'm not
saying that there isn't a really valid
need for other types of housing I just
don't see it as the local government's
responsibility no and well but and so
why I'm raising it is because I think
I think we absolutely
I believe we have a duty to be cognizant
of that need and then to try and meet
that need not of of a housing needle
across the Specter or not now whether
that's through lobbying you know and I
think the mayor's very good at that
um but equally do we look at our other
community
Partners you know
ilt Community Trust some of those ones
you know because really it's about the
community we we live in a you know those
we leave behind
you know it just doesn't sit well with
me
I get there but do we do we become a
provider or we do we find some
non-financial rates impact way of
finding so methods of supporting other
organizations to meet that need yeah so
I I probably agree we it's not our need
to meet in terms of our financial
impasse on rate payers but it is in a
duty to meet that need through other
means and mechanisms
okay
um through self chair I just want to
remind councils about the elderly um
housing activity and from that
perspective it is purely ring fenced
around being elderly housing portfolio
and the social housing component that
you're starting to get into it's more
around what we do in relation to our
district plan and working with our
community and organizations from that
perspective what land we make available
it's not part of this particular
activity it is a broader discussion from
a council perspective yes we definitely
have a role from that perspective as
Council will know in making land
available and those sort of things and
and in our concerning processes but this
activity is around the elderly housing I
think the confusions come in when we
were talking about the ewe component
with the 30 aspect that was still with
the criteria in relation to our elderly
housing um portfolio so it's still early
housing not going into any of the social
housing component from that perspective
well it's not where we're shifting I
think that in my mind it's actually
leaning back against that and say well
should we just be talking about elderly
housing shouldn't is there a rewarding
we need to give consideration to so well
the paper might call it early housing is
the it's housing for me but anyway
um
probably appropriate for me the chip in
there um so
um here that you say you're doing a
housing policy is that a housing policy
in relation to just the stock we've got
at the moment or is it a wider housing
it is just in relation to our elderly
housing yep that's fine
so um what Tom and I have been working
on and you've heard a little bit of
already is a little bit about the
discussion you've had chair with um
with Darren um I think we need to have
more fingers in the housing pie than
we've currently got that's not at the
expense of the Elderly Care the only
care should be maintained in those 215
units at the current criteria and they
should not be subsidizing ongoing growth
because we've got growth potential some
other way so I just run through a list
of what's been happening in the last
couple of months uh you've heard from
Michael and Aaron about the 100 houses
um and so what Tom and I were promoting
with ewe was that we'd have um
government support for 100 beds a
hundred units uh two bed units not one
bed units that gives opens up a
different class of client coming in
there so it could be somebody that might
want to have their children come as well
and stay from time to time it might open
up to people
um two elderly people living in the same
unit having company being a bit more on
a commercial basis
um one of the restrictions we have at
the moment for that type of development
is the issue around our current
Criterion eligibility of getting in so
one of the things that we're trying to
do with those hundred units and some of
these other initiatives is to free up
the
um the market for the current family
homes now I know literally dozens of
people at my age who are sitting in two
and three and four bedroom homes that
they don't want to be there the court of
no man's land they can't get out and get
into our elderly care because their
eligibility criteria they've got too
much Equity but their Equity level is
not high enough to buy into book or
order Rowena Jackson's and there are no
townhouses around town
so they just stuck on those homes with
all the maintenance costs and everything
the girls that goes with it so one of
the one of the ways that I wasn't
visiting this is that the 100 two
bedroom units that come on might have a
different set of criteria to what we've
currently got on Elderly Care
um so it would be for the elderly Seeker
but not necessarily be at the level that
we've currently got it set out which is
really the very sharp end
um I agree with what's being said about
the need to stay away from the social
delivery that's going to Aura
responsible to developer or an MSD we
should stay way clear of that it's a
problematic area to get into because
those units are very very hard to manage
because the social needs to go with them
so we we know about the 100 bid units
and we're still pursuing it we've got to
pull away down south which is a 600
section A subdivision which seems to
have been paused and I think as a
council we need to initiate some action
in that area with the developer to say
to him
um look if you're not moving on with it
um free it up because I know there are
people investors that will prepare to
buy that whole project and to move it
forward now one of the levers that we've
got in there is we've got Rockdale Park
I understand
um as part of the consenting process
they got Rockdale Park which we own as a
green space it was a requirement of the
consent now if we withdraw that the
consent Falls over
um and now that's a reasonably
strong-handed way of doing it but we
can't just sit here with that
development sitting there on the horizon
because what happens with that is other
investors are not prepared to come into
the field when they see that sitting
there
with potentially 600 houses to go there
but nothing's happening with it so as a
council we need to move that along
in recent uh recent weeks I've had
approaches from three different
developers around Donovan Park which we
've been talking to Michael about and
trying to move that as quick as we can
because
um we have other needs in our community
as well and the other needs are in three
areas
I don't know how you quite put this but
quality housing I guess or top-end
housing is a need we've had feedback
from the whr group and from the Woodside
group
and Woodside in particular say if there
are not enough quality houses around the
top Executives will not come here and
live here they'll fly and fly out which
we don't want
um we want them to be able to build here
so we don't have enough space in that
area so as a council we are required
like all councils to make um land
available where we can or rezone so that
uh some of it can be residential so
working as fast as we can with the staff
to
um change the district plan to allow
some of that area north invercargill to
be developed and changing the
classification from
reserved to one of the residential
clusters so that we can get in there
yeah now opening that up then opens us
up to
um joint ventures so we might have to
sort of pause there yep
um so yeah and loop back to sort of the
conversation about the elderly just
around the
I mean the important discussions and I
think we lean into them a little bit yes
that
well-being
um on Tuesday sorry
it's probably slightly outside and we're
testing the boundaries of public forum
versus a commercially sensitive
negotiation
well I wasn't going to get into that but
what I was saying is that when you get
to Joint benches they've opened some
options for you it does so instead of us
just providing or instead of just
government providing there are
developers who will
given I mean you saw you heard what
Michael and Aaron had to say about
um us providing infrastructure and land
free of cost to to a joint venture with
the government and the government would
build the houses and then we get them
yes well we've got we've got developers
that are also interested in that sort of
concept as well yeah so I think we need
to start thinking outside the screen on
that yeah and I guess the last area
or two years of need is we've got a need
now in our city for retirement villages
which are slightly different to aged
care Villages yeah so they are if you
see the ones up north they are people
that are retiring out of the farming
sector around Southland who would
normally transition to a townhouse in
the city and then go on to aged care as
that Health need required yeah but there
aren't any
um there aren't any of those uh middle
steps there yeah the townhouses are not
available there's shorter there's very
very few of them come to America so they
are wanting retirement villages now
which is a Different Twist Again
um and then the last thing you you
raised is the issue of the tiny houses
we've had a presentation from them I'm
still connected with them and I will do
some further work with them but that
requires us as a council to change our
thinking around how we might allow four
or five or six tiny houses to Cluster
together on one piece of land yeah and I
think that's a huge potential for people
that are young that are struggling
that's that power the market yeah if
you're a solo person yeah the one of the
problems with the
not problems the challenges with the
tiny house singers the needs a
reclassification of the number of units
because it's measured by you know
kitchens I think yep manner kitchens
within the units I know yeah and so we
should have a some serious thinking
around that as well because it's real
potentially yeah true right
anything more uh just a little bit on
measuring performance
um
we're not intending to change our key
performance under Curtis very much um
maybe add a cup uh one regarding
maintenance inspections and perhaps a
trigger point in terms of renewal
programs or refurbishment programs
um
why can't why does 95 why can they not
be 100 Oxford is that a maintenance
record you know so that allows us a bit
of room for refurbishment and
maintenance Pro yeah
and
we allow ourselves about six weeks for
tenant moving out to a tenant moving in
yeah
um and that's classified as as occupancy
even though it's a just a someone is
coming in so it's they're not occupied
we don't we don't consider them occupied
if the tenants moved out and the new
tenant hasn't moved in so yeah this but
other that they are because because the
tenancy agreement isn't signed until
they actually move in
on the day so or the week before yeah
you raise a good point
because the private sector look at
income sources so they'll say you know
if somebody moves out and nobody else
Moves In for eight weeks
um well I've got a loss of income so
that drops the percentage now we should
be thinking about is the unit available
how quickly they're moving and out is
irrelevant yeah I think it's the only
thing that would stop there is that we
did a major fit out yeah we've took it
away from that I think that's a better
indicator of the actual sort of
a vision of the service
because that implies that you know we've
got 215 units that implies it what does
that work today 12 years are constantly
vacant that's not the case
um the asset management plan is included
in the property wider property Asset
Management plan
um and just whip it on risks and
challenges obviously a aging stock and
increasing demand
[Music]
um
the current mental income doesn't
support the renewal plan we have
um and you know just that consideration
for rates investment if we're looking at
that
that's us
any final questions
no okay well we are
ahead of time
do we do you want to do Democratic
process discussion now yeah
yeah
it'll just keep everyone on task and put
you between
lemon lunch
[Applause]
thank you
cure a counselor so
um
the Democratic process essentially
covers the work of two teams within
Council Michael Morris couldn't be here
today so I'm going to talk about his
elements relating to governance as well
um so here's a little summary of the
areas that are covered within the
Democratic process activity in the
governance area elections Council
meetings procedural documents
support for yourselves
um and the chief executive and the
leadership team and all the legal advice
and support that Council requires as
part of its operation
and then the other parts of the activity
are within the strategy policy and
engagement team
um strategy and advocacy I've just drawn
out climate change is one of the
particular areas of topic we've been
working on recently corporate planning
um obviously this part of this ltp
process is all part of that as well as
annual reports and annual plans but also
I've drawn out the SOI process the
statements of intent for different parts
of the organization but particularly
Economic Development the Great South
contract all our bylaws and policies
that guide the way that Council actually
implements its practice and then finally
the community engagement and Activation
so that includes consultation and
engagement grants and funding and the
activation activities so Community
boards would be included yes the bluff
yeah support for Bluff as well yeah
really good point
um
so really I think
I've drawn out the most relevant
strategic priorities
um that you focus on at the part at the
beginning of this ltp process
really
um crucial to this activity is
supporting your leadership and decision
making
um some of the things that are affecting
the work of the democratic process
activity is the changing demography
needs and expectations of the population
um
and I think
people's expectations of what local
government is of what democracy is and
how it should function is changing we're
seeing that in National Trends in terms
of changing or lowering levels of
satisfaction with councils across the
country
um
and also a changing expectation of how
Community should be involved in decision
making uh local government is a
representative democracy system the
community elects yourselves as
counselors to make decisions on
um on their behalf for the best
interests of the city we run
consultation and engagement in order to
be able to inform your decision-making
process and make it
um as um as useful as efficient as
possible people increasingly looking for
more collaborative approaches and ways
of working so that's something that
really is probably at the core of
thinking about how the Democratic
process looks going forward
um I think we are also seeing on a range
of issues increasing
um political division and Divergence of
views amongst the community with quite
strong views on different sides which
makes managing the consultation and
engagement process more complex
so this is an overview of the budget
within the Democratic process activity
significant amount of that budget
obviously goes to some of those aspects
such as
um great South's contractors within this
budget line
um all the funding allocation that you
give through the community well-being
fund
um as well as all the core operational
activities for Democratic process
um so
the points that Michael wanted to draw
out in terms of the governance aspects
of democratic process specifically was
just the increased work there is around
the leguma requests and Privacy Act
issues so as Community interest in
particular parts of community of council
activities grows that increases that
work obviously Community interest is
really positive but there is then a
resource required to serve that
um council is doing a lot which is great
which in terms of outcomes for the
community but as I think you're all
aware you're meeting quite frequently
and both formal council meetings and
workshops in order to be able to
progress that business through Council
as fast as efficient as are possible and
that requires an awful lot of governance
support to enable that to happen to
provide you with the information that
you need to make informed decisions and
then to liaise with the rest of the
organization to be able to enact those
decisions and finally Michael's just
flagging the ongoing again National
Trend
invercargill still sits very favorably
in relation to the rest of the country
but just engagement with the election
process itself and there is always just
a slow genuine General decline in terms
of that process and a lot of work's gone
in to try to make raise awareness allow
people to engage in different ways
different communities are increasingly
saying it would be useful to them to
have ways to vote that links to the
places that they meet which is great and
it's really good to be able to respond
to those needs but it is more resource
intensive to be able to do that
um the second thing I think that it's
useful to draw out is that Community
engagement piece I've covered it briefly
at the beginning of
um this presentation I'll just note
further that local government reform
paper does outline and quite a lot of
detail potential future Direction
forward for local government in terms of
moving into
a more participate participatory space
there's opportunities to look at ways of
testing that out in various forms indeed
Council has supported various
collaboration projects to achieve
um better outcomes and that's happening
in different areas across Council
um the Costello Park Legacy be one
example of that but increased resources
enable is necessary to enable that
Community engagement to work effectively
because it is a more a longer process
as a minimum really suggesting that we
need at least a 0.5 extra FTE to support
Community engagement and an increased
budget Associated to allow activities to
take place so I've just shown an
estimated cost for that
in terms of where you could save money
as it comes to the next stage of the
process when you're looking at ways to
manage the budget increases you could
consider reducing the community
well-being fund or reducing the levels
of funding to one or more of the grants
to the external organizations that are
funded through the long-term plan so
that's just something that you could
consider
um
another aspect that I think that
um you might want to give some thought
to is the welcoming communities program
this is uh an aspect that again has
looked to central government policy it
is an important program in terms of
supporting the increasing numbers of
newcomers to the city is it intended to
primarily support migrants and Refugee
integration but also just general
newcomer integration no matter where
people are coming from as we see
increased diversity of locations that
people arrive from to the city to live
and make their Home Retention of people
is important and at the moment
councilors operating this program with
no dedicated resource we are adding
additional projects as and when we can
and so it is recommended that we do need
some resource to enable that to move
forward
finally and a really important one which
I'll speak briefly about in terms of the
regional work that's been going on
climate change so a lot of work's been
happening to assess what needs to be
done on the two main pillars of climate
change which is mitigation and
adaptation so in terms of reducing
cancer the carbon impact of council's
own activities there are two aspects of
this there's first of all the ability to
measure and actually know what is
happening in terms of our carbon impact
and there is a a minimal amount of
funding that is required to enable that
to happen to pay for the external
consultant
um also recommending that you consider
an internal internal contestable fund
for carbon mitigation actions and or
offsetting so as a starting point for
consideration we're recommending two
hundred thousand a year
um
so essentially what that would be used
for is for any team across Council who
has a carbon reduction activity to be
able to put forward their proposals for
what that might look like and for money
to be available to invest in those
activities
um then council could consider if any of
that fund each year was unspent you
could either use it to offset your
carbon impact by purchasing carbon
offsets or reducing just music rolling
it forward to next year essentially and
I know the finance people are going to
tell me that's the wrong term but
essentially meaning you don't have to
increase the rates quite as much the
next year and finally we don't yet have
an indication from environment South and
as to what the funding requirements are
likely to look like on this but we do
know we have received the report which
you received back in March from a
consultant showing that we're not able
to do the full assessment yet as to the
risk that our city assets are at from
climate change because further data
analysis and modeling is needing to be
done and we now do have the core data
has just been finalized from lidar but
there is quite a bit of a lot of further
modeling and assessment which will take
quite a considerable amount of time to
land
um environments often are in the process
of analyzing what that might look like
but we do not yet know how much it might
cost the coastal inundation part is the
part that is the most important to the
city so I'm just putting in a
placeholder there
given we don't know the cost
implications
and finally in terms of measuring the
performance of the democratic process
activity
um the two kpis you can see at the top
are kpis that we already have and we're
proposing keeping those but
adding two new kpis which would be
around climate change and voter
participation in elections and those
would monitor some of the other aspects
of the activity so I'm happy to take any
questions
great
um I'm gonna start awesome
I'll start at the back and we'll work
forward so the climate change one
now where did we factor that into
sending a delegation to kumagaya
obviously jet travel International jet
travel huge impact on climate change
there's no denying that how do you how
do you do we have to buy carbon credits
to do that or you know this is we we
don't want to be hypocritical on this
erase this account so 134 and it didn't
get anywhere
oh I don't think so
I think it was I don't recall it getting
anywhere Patricia
um through your chair um to withdraw
this Darren
I'm wondering what your expected outcome
is yeah oh I know to keep the chair
happy y'all Patricia and the last straw
I was drawn no no in relation to
kumagaya the council paper that went up
in relation to that asked whether
Council wanted to offset the carbon
credits in relation to the travel if my
recollection was correct we voted
against it
against it yeah
okay the next one's regarding
um ccos and obviously you mentioned
Great South now accountability there
um I don't believe
we are seeing accountability
via the mechanism that's listed in there
SOI and their SOI it states
that they they have no surprises policy
via the shareholders uh committee is
this related to
um governance yes yes that's right I'm
I'm saying the governance is that we
don't have
we don't have that accountability and
governance
speak briefly to that so you will be
receiving
um papers to the August council meeting
on these matter so it's probably the
most appropriate time yeah that specific
issue yeah
right you're referencing a decision
that's been made by them recently wrong
no no
just general okay that's it yeah and the
other list the other one
the other one is about your engagement
for the public the ability to influence
decisions
and there was quite a low percentage but
I I think that
um
my my take on it is that the Public's
ability main ability and their first
ability is in the election process of
who they vote for because really if
they're going to vote for X person
might be a well-known name might be
something might be anything before they
vote for someone who they actually align
with there's two different ways of
voting so if they if they like to align
and I suppose it's getting to know the
candidates better whatever but by
putting someone in that you
can hold accountable then that's a start
of influencing governance okay then
after that we've got
Consulting and stuff like that but if
you don't get the first bit right
you know as far as the public goes they
can't really say that we don't have
um any way to influence it yeah yeah
okay thank you
um just you had a thing near Rhiannon 21
after years
back on one of the first ones yeah so
that's actually directly people involved
in the governance process at the council
or as that sort of pulling part people
that do some work in the governance
space but maybe another
that's across the whole Democratic
process activity so that includes all of
the governance support but also that all
of the strategy policy Community
engagement activation and management of
the sois all all of the whole yeah
activity yeah yeah okay so then with
your request for
um particularly around
um you know Community voice in in some
of those things
um
have you looked at
um here you could sort of redistribute
workload change Focus within the
existing fde thing or is it I think
there's a reference here you need a
0.550
yes so
um I'll speak briefly to that and then
Michael might have something additional
that he wishes to say so yes across the
engagement and the welcoming communities
we're proposing we need another FTE
um we are extremely like relievers
almost compared to most councils in the
engagement space we are already only
covering all of the work through an
extreme amount of juggling acts and
um the issue that we're facing is that
there has been quite a significant and
steep
change that we are experiencing in the
community in terms of how they want to
participate and the risks to council
staff of managing that participation
safely
um so part of that
speaks to the point that councilor
poringer was making in that people are
ex are wanting to get more involved in
decision making
um in terms of engaging more deeply and
over multiple Hui in some areas and then
the other area is we are seeing some
parts of the community being more heated
in their in their views and creating
situations where we need to have more
staff present in order to manage those
conversations in an appropriate way
um so did you want it
through soft here look the only thing I
wear to that because Ren's spoke very
well on that particular item the only
item I'd add is that we are
compensating some of the Gap I would say
in relation to those public events by
actually using staff from outside the
governance process to to help support so
we have those coverage and that that
does include using some of the executive
team to actually be present in those
particular meetings to make sure that we
have
uh the right support available to our
team so we are running a fairly lean
governance team by comparison across the
country
so so what from here you would actually
put up a paper or detail out some of the
sort of whatever explanation you've just
given in much more granular detail
for a decision that what the next
process would be so the same for as of
for every activity you'll receive the
activity plans later this year for
review but the next stage of this
process is budgeting so there will be
workshops bringing all the options
forward but that's why we're seeking
feedback now from everyone and when your
perspectives and that's how we'll build
the final plans yeah
don't we
um so I'll just run through my view of
the three years that have been thrown up
um
yeah and the first one on the community
engagement they've got an estimated cost
of 75 000 for a part-time position so
that means an FTE of 150 000 so be
interesting to know what we're actually
in recruiting there that seems to be an
awfully High salary I know there'll be
factors in here around vehicle use and
yeah I know but that even if the effect
of 10 or 15 out of that's an awfully
High salary range for somebody who's
going to connect with me so I don't
support I don't support that well hang
on sorry I'm just giving my Beyond here
and others can then contribute so we had
a community development team for those
who've been here long enough to remember
which is under Mary Napa in the past we
want that functional way uh with with
good reason so I don't I don't support
that
um I don't support any reduction to the
community well-being fund I'd need a
paper to justify what the impact that is
when I hear I often hear people say
within Council you know why do we have
such a an annual commitment to that fund
when we've got iot and uh ctOS in some
areas uh contributing already but
um it's too easy just to say yeah I know
that so on news about reducing that down
um and on the welcoming Community things
it's my understanding that we've already
got some government and some iot funded
positions already in the community so
down in the old um
uh plunket rooms sitting down on Fourth
Street there is an organization in there
that does exactly that they welcome in
different ethnic groups plus we've got
the um
Multicultural Network within a city that
seems to work reasonably well you see
them here at all the citizenship
um ceremonies so again I'm not
supportive of that either and on the
issue of the climate change I mean
the three outcomes that are there way
too subjective for me
um certainly around a contestable fund I
don't know whether it's a council's role
to have a contestable fund anyway which
is 200 000 a year and then the um the
final thing there around our Coastal
Innovation stuff look I've been
listening for probably the best part of
two years waiting for around South to
get that leader data to us they don't
have it yet until we've got there we've
got no idea of of where this will impact
but it seems to me the leader
information is more about water flows
within our Rivers as opposed to what's
actually happening on the coast itself
um so again from my perspective I
wouldn't commit to any of that until
because it suggests that 75 000 a year
contribution until we had a whole lot
more data from environment Southland as
well so this is my view of the world
friend
um so just to clarify specifically on
the community engagement part you're
right that would be a high salary for
that it's not intended to discover
salary at present we have a very small
um almost non-existent budget for
actually hiring venues printing
collateral all of that kind of thing
which really limits the ability of us to
run a lot of the Hui
um so that part of that is a proposed
increase in that ability to actually
fund sure I understand that but I guess
if you're going out to the community are
we are we now splitting off and saying
well I'll go and talk to Darren up there
because he's just part of the general
Community about engagement because
that's one of our core functions to do
there but then I'll go and talk to
Michael because he's a new immigrant or
at least come from Gisborne recently and
I'll talk to him through a separate
process I mean I would have thought
communicatement as Community engagement
if we've got barriers for people coming
forward which I suspect we have right
across our population we don't get a lot
of participation that a lot of stuff we
put out public consultations on a food
ranging and others talk about that in
the past we put out something for public
submission we get 20 or 30 sets of
feedback it's pretty dismal from a a
rate payer base of 25 000 or whatever it
is
um so we've got a problem right across
the board and why are we just targeting
some new immigrant source and
um
um some migrants whatever I think we've
got we've got groups in in our
committees that already help those
people uh come forward anyway I think
we've got a much wider problem and
that's what we should be potentially
targeting not just having somebody goes
out and talk to migrant groups or people
that have come from outside invercargill
which could be somebody coming from
Dunedin
yeah I think if I come up a little bit
um
it's important but it's equally
challenging isn't it to sort of hear the
voice of the community but not be
sort of captured by a few noisy voices
in the community and
um
you know I think what I'd be Keen to see
I think it's really important we sort of
stay as connected as possible to our
Collective Community voice you know
and then you know how you use really
Innovative in modern stuff to connect to
them you know so your SurveyMonkey thing
pops up but there's probably more
iterations of those sorts of things that
happen on social media with you like see
a tick tock which ring you better tell
us about and those sorts of things but
um you know just so that we can you know
you're not going to get the solution but
yet there's two things you're achieving
one you're feeling as though people want
to have a say they can in a forum that's
appropriate then there's a
responsibility there for both to provide
and to use properly and then secondly
how you can light up that that voice
into a centralized sort of okay what's
the overall theme that's coming out of
this
um and but equally I think it's
important to you know think Rhiannon
outlined it really well is you know you
have got right through globally
you know
um very
secular groups emerging around very
particular interests that can make a
whole lot of noise
and can get quite aggressive on the
approach to get the outcome that they
see for them which is poorly considered
in my view so we've just got to be
cautious of how that evolution of
society is impacted on voice and all
those sorts of things that's a blooming
difficult
yeah so we're just somehow we've got to
think through to in my view it's really
important we have Community voice as a
key part of how we make decisions and
informed decision
both immediately and long term and then
here we can click that up on a most
effective and efficient way to reflect
that voice by using technology that sort
of restricts you know the just growing
cost
so so I want to support that initiative
if it was a wider perspective and not
just migrants and yeah and things like
that because you're quite right I mean
look I
I mean I've been out to different groups
recently in Pacific area and then I've
had people approach me from the Samoan
here who are one of the two largest
groups within the Pacifica cluster and
they say they feel a bit lost in that
wider thing it's a little bit like when
you talk to disability sector they'll
say they've got 23 percent of the
population are disabled in one form or
another
getting down to wearing glasses as well
but then when you go and talk to the
blind or low vision people they feel
quite lost in that wider cluster so how
do we get to those smaller voices is the
key issue and how do we set mechanisms
in place
um where we can get to groups that one
aren't good with technology or two don't
have English as a first the initial
language so somebody coming in from
Colombia is going to struggle to input
into something here and that's where I
think this and my
here it goes is how do we solve that
problem which is you know
um
you know and it even is there's no
better benefit than pushing the person
the flesh with people you know just you
know so maybe us as counselors need to
be more active in air constitutions
now some are and some aren't right but
so does that
process we get into what is part of an
overall governance consultation role
um how do we speak that voice back and
not just put our hands on that voice
yeah and again when we first started
that when I first started out in Council
um I I post that problem to people you
know you come here you get a mandate
from the community because you get x
amount of votes but how do you still
keep connected I mean you get it through
if you play golf or you're involved with
the Rugby Union whatever but it's not
wide enough no and we don't we don't
capture them
um and it was good that we went out
Rihanna's team went out recently did the
18 to 30 alt
um because we had a lot of information
out of that that we would not have
expected what I would not have expected
um so we will continue to look for
opportunities now that involves a
half-time worker
um I'd be really supportive of that but
just narrowing it down to just those
small groups to me is going in the wrong
direction yeah yeah I I can I can accept
and agree with that
um there were other ways of consultation
that we've used in the past some of
which are no longer opened us we did use
Regional television and did live
TalkBack for a while which was fraught
um but Innovative and well received we
used to do clinics
where we went out people could come you
know we had a couple of councilors
designated and people could come to us
and talk about anything they wanted now
they weren't
hugely used but but they were an
opportunity but what it seems to be that
we're getting feedback that people are
looking for and this comes to what
nobby's been saying and what we've
experienced with some recent Marco
Locker engagement is that people want us
to go to them and them as not a large
Collective group at small individual
groups which is just in some senses
Beyond or the sort of thing that you
might be able to do once or twice a
trianium but but bearing in mind how
much time
just the regular work of council takes
um and
while we're using more online options
for people giving feedback sometimes
what we're getting and by way of
feedback is just quite simply trolling
again you've got to be careful about how
you
uh apply weight to it but it's it's a
necessity because the ways of us
communicating what it is that we want to
people
have changed dramatically and the
traditional methods are no longer is
have the same reach that they used to
um but it's going to require more
resource and supporting that I think is
is a good idea another Innovative thing
I saw in there was the potential 200
contestable fund for carbon reduction
now that's that's thinking outside the
box it was raised I think in a previous
workshop and I think it's a great idea
that might inspire people from within
the organization to think okay yeah what
what can we do because
you've got how many staff and how many
potential ideas and it's regardless of
what we're waiting from in the way of
leadership from from the regional
Authority around climate change it's a
step that we can start to take ourselves
and say when someone says well what are
you doing well here's here's something
that we're trying and I think that's
really really good yeah my question here
and it's a bit and comes up in the
commercial World should you have to
incentivize people in the role to do
that thinking or should they just be
doing it anyway and and my challenge
would be in the current world If you're
sort of not thinking about the impact of
climate change and all those sorts of
things and everything you're doing in
your role
your preps but is it incentivizing or is
it saying this is the amount of money
we're going to put into it who's able to
come up with suggestions for it best to
be put to use
because it's not you know I don't see it
as being paid to the staff directly it's
it's going towards the projects
yeah just just to give some perspective
for Council on thinking about all those
engagement activities that you've talked
about um I just want to remind us we
have just come out of covert period and
uh the nature of our activities has
changed significantly
um pre and post and we're starting to
get back more into that physical
activity and personal engagement
components so some of the things that we
were doing in the past are starting to
happen again
um particularly around those big
community events we've had a number of
those recently we've brought a lot of
people in to have discussions
that does and that's what we're alluding
to is it was it was easy to manage when
we didn't have those of hints we didn't
have our people having to be out there
we're starting to see that coming back
on and it's becoming um resource intense
so we're just that's primarily what it's
indicating is there is a resource Gap in
relation to that as we've changed and
gone through the covert period we're
able to cope with it a little bit better
um during covert because we
um weren't physically connected from
that perspective we're having to do a
lot more remote sessions but now we're
increasing our physical presence out
there in community engagement
yeah so just before I come to you yep
um so you'll there's a paper another
Workshop going to be here on the
specific laser
is that what you're thinking so
um no you'll receive the items for
decision as part of the next report
rounds and you'll make those decisions
and we're taking all the feedback from
these workshops to finalize what's
brought to you yeah yeah
it's to me it's quite a wide topic that
it's probably worth a specific
it's really important we get this right
um you know in my head even floats
around you know are we fulfilling our
roles as counselors as fully as we could
should be or should there be a review of
Council or remuneration so they can
become more
you know have more time available to do
this sort of thing I mean it's one of
those things you have to ask the
question two wrong who should be getting
the voice is should it be governance
and staff or staff collecting it for
governance what you know what all those
sorts of things need to be discussed and
determined Molly
um a couple of things just respond to
Michael's one to start with
um one of the things I've been thinking
about is we we carry quite a few
vacancies a significant number of
vacancies actually
um I think one stage 40 or 50.
um I would have thought that this sort
of activity spread where you want to
refocus your organization would be
within your control wouldn't require an
extra position potentially
added to the system
um that we would have that capacity
already to focus somebody for a year or
two
but I agree with you grant um but when
we go to consult on major issues and we
get very poor responses and one of the
things that we should decide before we
go out to consultations how do we
actually want to do it is the
traditional way of doing it like Darren
says it's not cervous as well can we as
elector members also Target groups so if
we want to sell rugby park for over sake
if that was something on the agenda we'd
have people here that would go and talk
to the Rugby Union but you know if there
are wide rushes where do we get out it
was a standing joke when I first joined
Council and Leslie won't mind me saying
this that she used to be everywhere with
her red coat on which is her labor coat
and look and even today everywhere I go
in the community where there's issues
around multiculturalism about migrant
workers wherever she's always there so
that's that's a challenge for the rest
of us to be out there yeah and engaging
in that way now not everybody's got that
time and space
um but we we should Target yeah so if we
want to engage on application who's
going to put the hand up and go yeah go
places and I've been thinking about that
quite a bit we'll come to Iran and maybe
that's a function that we could use the
government staff to do to create those
opportunities for example the schools
you know maybe it's
if you know an opportunity to go and sit
with school children you know or the
schools and talk through them at
assembly time for example might be a
really great opportunity for us as
Governors to go out and just hear the
voice of that particular constituency
right even though they don't vote
they're still an important Voice or you
know that's just the example but so
maybe this but I think we should Target
issues we've got something special we
want to go do
because if he's got to the school you
know you can talk about lots of things
but doesn't really impact what the staff
are looking for engagement on some key
issues yeah um well I was thinking about
going out to listen not talk but but it
comes down to everything and each
individual issue because some of the
stuff we go out to consult on is not
interesting to me yeah yeah and that's
why sometimes there's so little to the
mayor's point I think we need to step
right back to our governance level and
say okay what are we trying to achieve
through this and then how's the best
mechanism to achieve it and is it us is
it staff is a combination is it
technology is it interest groups is it
General ketchup
you know whatever we but we've got to
have an actual strategy and almost come
even further back we've got to have a
vision for what does really good
governance look like for us around
Community engagement
and then that leads us through to our
actions which leads us through to it
I think one one of the good examples for
that me was a couple of years ago we had
the rate increases with their uh
their units and we just put that out in
the document and assume that everybody
is sitting on those 250 units would
engage of course clearly they didn't but
it created a real storm and we'd sort of
hitter that we might have put a couple
of councils on a couple of Staff members
out to a meeting just for those people
by the long morning or afternoon tea are
involved I know what took was one piece
of misinformation it didn't and they
turned us blew out of control and it's a
good point isn't it because you can have
the best intentions around governance
but if your actions don't connect with
that you shoot yourself from two feet
yep did you want to say something for a
company yeah so just to respond to the
um suggestion of having another Workshop
we could certainly do that last ltp
round we Workshop this in detail and
it's all within the significance and
engagement policy that directs our
principles for engagement that was all
put together by the
um previous Council so we can certainly
review that every report that you
receive on a particular issue or
consultation includes the proposed
approach for the engage and we vary it
for every single issue
um to be specific to the stakeholders
involved and whether it's a broad public
interest issue or whether it's specific
stakeholders every approach is varied
um providing those varied approaches
it's more labor intensive because you
need to change up what you're doing for
every situation we certainly have a
counselor-led approach to all engagement
and that's why we'll I'll often be on
the phone reaching out saying hey
darling can you come to this particular
Hui
um
or I guess I would advise it will be a
very labor intensive from the collection
of the feedback point of view if you
have no officers involved in that
um in my experience that is a step
that is beyond what should be the
councilor's role somebody has to collect
the information and put it formally into
the decision-making process
um but we certainly always looking for
Innovative new approaches but it is it
is labor intensive
yeah let's just reinforce exactly what I
see yeah which was we need to we need to
look at the much wider picture of how we
engage with their Community not just the
smaller ones or anybody and I'd support
a position yeah that did exactly that
except we we should we should take the
initiative to say hey it's not a matter
of just going out
um
if you organize the workshop you went
down and hit a Hui and someone come up
with a really great idea and you
directed them to go to our app and put
that feedback in because that's great at
feedback we want to capture that you
know that to me is smart as opposed to
counselor trying to remember what was
said or staff member turning up to try
and record what was said let's leverage
technology to capture the voice
you know so we've stimulated the
discussion kitchen I mean a good example
is we we head on there today I think on
one of the presentations about
um a potential transport link would
Bluff yeah now logic would tell me why
haven't we surveyed every household and
Bluff to find out how many people would
use a bus and if we have and we find out
this
50 trips a week then you might put on
three return trips or four return trips
if there's 200 then you might put on a
whole lot more but we just don't seem to
engage that one that's right we get a
new idea we jump in and do it and then
find out the buses that have only got
one personal
did you run it
no no no sorry yeah so do do you want
some direction around whether we have a
separate workshop on this particular
issue now would yep what are you feeling
oh I'd like to have one I think that's
the big gap for us I think it's a good
opportunity to bring in the new Council
as everybody haven't had any input of
that before and we've also got a few
voices missing that are pretty important
to hear from this here can we yes
um touch base just on the FTE FTE side
of it um I think that's got
um a lot of air time but it's actually
quite confusing because it's actually
not actually about FTE in relation to
the resourcing because it's about
whether you want the work to be that
work to be done or not and quite rightly
put from the mirror is um when it comes
down to resourcing that I need to work
out and the balance across
um whatever resources I've got available
to actually achieve that outcome
um but it's about whether you want that
work done or not and I know that my CFO
down the end will tell me she always
already allows for my vacancies and
assumes I'm not going to recruit a
certain amount during the year so um
I'll need to do some dealing down the
end in relation to that
but from perspective of FTS it's quite
right I need to work within within
whatever ftes I have but it whatever
budget that Council want to get from the
right Pairs and what services you want
to provide so we probably worded it
wrong by saying it's an additional FTE
it's an additional work requirement
Frankie did you want to yeah let's
really I mean 30 News on Council and
what I've seen is
in my own experience as well is that
just human nature is that
like unless you're affected you're not
really too involved that's right and you
know I mean a classic one will be Sandy
Point management plan yeah that's going
to get a lot of feedback because of the
diverse use I mean I I was a rate payer
for 25 years before I even realized you
know what council actually did and which
affected me so I didn't really get a
consultation I just stood for Council I
thought there'd be an easy way to sort
the problem out is from the inside yeah
you still think it was a good decision
uh yeah I'm working on it's working
progress
but really like if you look at the role
of a cat the role of a councilor like
the Local Government Act actually has a
job description for the mayor it does
it's quite clear what the mayor's role
is but there is no job description at
all for a counselor anywhere in the act
but it's an opportunity for us to you
know to sort of well I mean it'd be
great to actually we could create our
own it looks like yeah yeah I mean I
mean I get phone calls every day you
know people ringing up about stuff I I
got one yesterday that the um
Don street now feeds onto D Street and
the sensor that realizes there are cars
in Don Street wanting to get onto D
Street has been misbehaving so so I got
a call to um and of course Russell
Pearson sees my name come up on the
phone and goes oh you know so it is
true barking dogs back with dogs
and anyway anyway so I mean it works I
think the counselors if they get
familiar with us
um I think that's the best way is make
make yourself very open very